I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, everybody. Hello. Are you ready for Season 7, Episode 20, Training Day? I am so ready. I laughed so flippin' hard watching this episode. I feel like we need to give people an update on our studio situation since we did talk about it last week, Angela. Okay.
我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。大家好。大家好。你们准备好迎接第七季第二0集《培训日》了吗？我已经准备好了。看这一集时我笑得要死。安吉拉，我觉得我们上周谈过后，需要向大家更新一下我们的工作室情况。好的。
I think they have the lease on these offices for what? Maybe three more days? Maybe three more hours. We've come in to the Erewolf offices. There is literally nothing here. It feels like three more hours, like it really does, because there's nothing. I thought, oh, when I get there, maybe I'll get a glass of water. There's nothing. There's no glasses. Like Dunder Mifflin, going through a transition, we are also going through a transition of space. They're going through a transition of manager. Look at you, girl. Look at you. We're going through a transition of space. Yeah.
我想他们对这些办公室的租约还有多久？大概还有三天吧？也许还有三个小时。我们来到了爱狼（Erewolf）办公室。这里简直什么都没有。感觉就像只剩三个小时了，真的有这种感觉，因为这里空无一物。我当时想，噢，我到了那里之后，也许能喝上一杯水。这里什么都没有。连杯子都没有。就像邓德米夫林一样，正在经历转型，我们也正在经历空间的转型。他们正在经历经理的转型。看看你，女孩。看看你。我们正在经历空间的转型。是的。
Well, listen, Training Day was written by Daniel Chun. It was directed by Paul Lieberstein, and here is your summary. The Dunder Mifflin Scranton branch has found a replacement manager. His name is D'Angelo Vickers, but Michael is having a hard time letting go, especially because the employees seem to be fawning over D'Angelo. Meanwhile, Dwight is struggling with the fact that he was not even considered for the manager position. Oh, that is a blow. Fast fact number one, I mean, D'Angelo Vickers was played by Will Ferrell. We were all so giddy. Remember, Jenna, we just could not wait to show up on set the
听着，《培训日》由丹尼尔·陈编剧。由保尔·利伯斯坦执导，剧情梗概如下。邓德米夫林斯克兰分公司找到了新的代理经理。他叫德安吉洛·维克斯，但迈克尔很难放手，尤其是因为员工们似乎都在奉承德安吉洛。与此同时，德怀特正为自己甚至没有被列入经理人选而苦苦挣扎。哦，这真是一个打击。趣味事实一，我是说，德安吉洛·维克斯由威尔·法瑞尔饰演。我们当时都兴奋极了。记得吗，珍娜，我们简直迫不及待地想在第一天出现在片场，
first day and be in scenes with him. Yes. This began our four episode arc with Will. We had a fan question from Sierra P and Oregon. How did Will Ferrell end up with this role? Was it specifically written for him? Yes, Sierra, this role was written for Will. And here is the crazy way that he ended up on our show. Will called the producers at the beginning of the season and offered to come in at some point to do a cameo because he knew it was Steve's last season. And our producers were like, hey, how about a show like, what, what, what? Yeah, okay. Yeah, they were for four episodes. And he totally agreed. When we announced Will's arc to the
和他一起拍戏。是的。这开启了我们与威尔合作的四集戏份。我们收到了来自俄勒冈州席亚拉·P的粉丝提问。威尔·法瑞尔是如何得到这个角色的？这是专门为他写的吗？是的，席亚拉，这个角色就是为威尔写的。以下是他加入我们节目的疯狂过程。威尔在赛季初给制作人们打电话，主动提出在某个时候客串一下，因为他知道这是史蒂夫的最后一季。我们的制作人们当时想，嘿，弄个节目怎么样，什么，什么，什么？是的，好吧。是的，他们拍了四集。他完全同意了。当我们向媒体
press, we made our press release. Paul Lieberstein, who was the showrunner at the time, had this very funny quote. He said, quote, we found Steve Carell when he was nothing but a movie star and we turned him into a television star. We are proud to continue the office's tradition of discovering famous talent. And we hope that one day America gets a good look at Will Ferrell. They'll see what we see. Tremendous raw sexuality. That was this quote to welcome Will Ferrell to the show. All right, fast back. Number two is a fan question from Bernice C and upland, California, who asks, was it ever a possibility that Will Ferrell was going to be the permanent Scranton Dunder Mifflin manager? No, it was not a possibility.
宣布威尔的戏份时，我们发布了新闻稿。当时的剧集运作人保尔·利伯斯坦说了句非常搞笑的话。他说，引述如下，我们在史蒂夫·卡瑞尔还只是个电影明星时就发现了他是谁，并把他打造成了电视明星。我们很自豪能延续《办公室》发掘知名人才的传统。我们希望有一天美国能好好看看威尔·法瑞尔。他们会看到我们所看到的东西。巨大的原始性感魅力。这就是欢迎威尔·法瑞尔加入剧组的这段话。好的，趣味事实。
And we all knew that we were just lucky to get him. Yeah, totally. We actually asked Greg Daniels about Will joining the show. And here's what he had to say. I think there was a feeling of can the show survive without Steve and everybody wanted it to we all felt like there is so much vitality in the ensemble cast. There were more stories to tell Steve did not want to kill the show with his exit. And so there was this feeling of don't save his exit to the very, very end of the season and then have all summer for fans to be like, well, I'm done, you know, we wanted to have him exit a little before the end of the season and then have some sort of treat for people to keep watching. And so Will Ferrell was
第二条是来自加州乌普兰的伯尼斯·C的粉丝提问，他问，威尔·法瑞尔有没有可能成为斯克兰邓德米夫林常驻经理？不，这是不可能的。我们都知道能请到他已经是我们的幸运了。是的，完全如此。我们实际上问过格雷格·丹尼尔斯关于威尔加入剧组的事。他是这么说的。我想当时有一种感觉，没有了史蒂夫，这个节目还能生存下去吗？每个人都希望如此，我们都觉得演员阵容充满活力。还有更多的故事要讲。史蒂夫并不想在他退出的时候毁了这个节目。所以当时的感觉是，不要把他的退出留到赛季的最末尾，然后让粉丝们整个夏天都觉得，好吧，我受够了，你知道的，我们希望他在赛季结束前不久退出，然后给观众一些继续观看的惊喜。所以威尔·法瑞尔就是
the treat. We were all very excited to have Will Ferrell and and he was good friends with Steve and it seemed like, you know, something to signal to people like life would go on, there'd be exciting, you know, other comedy people that we could bring in and also took a little pressure off probably like whoever would have been the next boss right after Steve would it would have been very difficult probably. It was good to have a little palette cleanser in there. So Will was our treat and our palette cleanser writer Danny Chen said that it was a huge relief because everyone was so nervous about what is that first episode going to be without
这个惊喜。我们都很高兴能请到威尔·法瑞尔，而且他和史蒂夫是好朋友，这似乎向人们发出了一个信号，生活会继续，会有令人兴奋的其他喜剧演员我们可以请来，这也可能减轻了一点压力，无论谁是史蒂夫之后的下一任老板，那都可能会非常困难。能在其中起到一点调剂作用是很好的。所以威尔是我们的惊喜和调剂，编剧丹尼·陈说这真是一个巨大的解脱，因为每个人都对没有了史蒂夫的第一集会是什么样感到非常紧张，而且知道他们在那一集中有威尔作为过渡，对编剧们来说真是一份大礼。我敢说压力全无。而且当时他们也没有选出新经理。我还记得幕后的轰动。
Steve and knowing that they would have will for that episode as a bridge was such a gift for the writers. I bet like no pressure. And at this time too, they had not picked a new manager. I remember the hubbub behind the scenes. So much hubbub. They had so many people coming in and out and there were names being thrown around and you'd see people coming in for meetings and it would be like. That's what we would do guys. It is. We wouldn't even say words. We would just say oh my gosh. Yeah. Isn't that what you do on stage? If you have to do like background party atmosphere. Do you remember that in high school? We'd be like spaghetti. Spaghetti. Spaghetti. Spaghetti. Go to get a bowl of spaghetti. Peace and carrots.
太轰动了。他们有那么多人进进出出，各种名字被抛出来，你会看到人们进来开会，然后就会觉得。这就是我们会做的，伙计们。是的。我们甚至不用说词。我们只会说，噢，天哪。是的。这不就是你在舞台上会做的事吗？如果你必须营造背景派对气氛的话。你还记得高中时那样吗？我们会说，意大利面。意大利面。意大利面。意大利面。去买一碗意大利面。和平与胡萝卜。和平与胡萝卜。
Peace and carrots. Peace and carrots. Yeah. All right. Fasback number three. This is a fan question from Becca H and Glasgow, Scotland. What was it like to work with Will Ferrell? Was this the first time most of you were meeting him? And do you want to go first? Sure. I had never met Will. I was so excited. I was such a big fan and he was the most kind just normal fellow. Just felt like you were talking to your neighbor across like the hedge in your front lawn. He was just wonderful. I just remember I have such a distinct memory
和平与胡萝卜。是的。好的。趣味事实三。这是来自苏格兰格拉斯哥的贝卡·H的粉丝提问。和威尔·法瑞尔合作是什么感觉？这是你们大多数人第一次见他吗？你想先说吗？当然。我以前没见过威尔。我太兴奋了。我是他的超级粉丝，而他是最亲切、最普通的人。感觉就像你在前院的树篱旁和邻居说话一样。他真是太棒了。我只记得，我有一个非常清晰的记忆，
walking into the soundstage one afternoon and he was just right outside. He had just been talking to his kids and I walked up and we talked about being parents and he was just lovely. I just absolutely liked him so much as a person and then of course I could not stop laughing in every scene with him. He was so funny. He is so naturally funny too. He'll say a sentence that is there's nothing about the sentence that's funny, but when he says that it's funny or just a look, just his expressions would just kill me. Well I had had the chance to work with Will before on Blades of Glory. So I knew Will,
有一天下午走进摄影棚，他就站在外面。他刚跟孩子们通完电话，我走过去，我们聊了聊当父母的感受，他真的很可爱。我真的非常喜欢他这个人，当然了，和他在一起的每一场戏我都笑得停不下来。他太搞笑了。他也自带幽默感。他会说一句话，这句话本身一点也不搞笑，但当他说出来时就很搞笑，或者仅仅是一个眼神，他的表情就能把我逗乐。嗯，我有过和威尔合作的经验，之前在《冰刀双人组》里。所以我认识威尔，
but I think I've told this story before for whatever reason, every time I meet Will again or I encounter Will after all these years and it happened here as well, I always introduce myself to him with my first and last name and remind him how he knows me. He's like, Jenna, I know who you are. We've worked together multiple times. Stop introducing yourself. I'm like, hey Will, Jenna Fisher, we work together on Blades of Glory and then again on the office and he's like, Jenna, I know you, but I don't know, he just, he's such a down to earth guy, but his stature and his like just legendary status, it always makes
但我好像讲过这个故事，不管出于什么原因，每次我再见到威尔，或者这些年后再次偶遇威尔，这次也是一样，我总是用我的名和姓向他自我介绍，并提醒他他是怎么认识我的。他会说，珍娜，我知道你是谁。我们合作过多次。别再自我介绍了。我说，嘿，威尔，我是珍娜·费舍尔，我们在《冰刀双人组》里合作过，然后又在《办公室》里合作过，他就会说，珍娜，我认识你，但我不知道，他就是，他是一个非常脚踏实地的人，但他的身材和他的传奇地位，总是让
me feel like how many people does this guy encounter in a day and also he talks to every single person. He's so friendly. He's like you, Angela. Oh, well, thank you. I mean, 100% Will Ferrell is becoming best friends with whoever's sitting next to him on a plane. Oh yeah. You have that in common. This is true.
我觉得这家伙一天要遇到多少人啊，而且他跟每个人都说话。他太友好了。就像你一样，安吉拉。哦，谢谢。我是说，百分之百，威尔·法瑞尔会和飞机上坐在他旁边的人成为好朋友。哦，是的。你们有这个共同点。这是真的。
Well, that's all I got. All my fast facts were about Will Ferrell. I mean, this is his first episode. What can I say? I have a fun DVD tidbit for those of you that have the DVDs. There is an awesome extended producers cut of this episode. If you love Will Ferrell and you love Will and Steve together, you're going to want to go watch the extended cut because there is so much more of D'Angelo and Michael. And I'm going to sprinkle a few scenes in throughout the episode that were just too good. I have to share. I could watch hours of those two. So this is very good news to me.
好了，我只有这些了。我所有的趣味事实都是关于威尔·法瑞尔的。我是说，这是他的第一集。我能说什么呢？对于那些有DVD的听众，我有一个有趣的DVD花絮。这集有一个超赞的加长导演剪辑版。如果你喜欢威尔·法瑞尔，喜欢威尔和史蒂夫在一起，你一定要去看加长版，因为里面有太多关于德安吉洛和迈克尔的戏份了。我会在这一集中穿插几个太精彩而不得不分享的场景。我可以看这两个人好几个小时。所以这对我来说是个好消息。
Well, what do you think? Should we take a break? And then when we come back, we break down this episode. I think so because two strangers are going to find a friendship at a bar. Mm hmm. Mm hmm. We are back. And can you guess what this sound is? That's right. That's a Kahlua sombrero. Michael's drink. You know we had to try it. Sam, Cassie, Angelo.
那么，你们觉得呢？我们该休息一下吗？然后等我们回来，再来剖析这一集。我也这么觉得，因为两个陌生人要在酒吧里建立友谊了。嗯哼。嗯哼。我们回来了。你们能猜出这是什么声音吗？没错。那是卡鲁阿咖啡甜酒（Kahlua）加咖啡利口酒鸡尾酒，也就是迈克尔的饮料。你知道我们必须尝尝。萨姆、卡西、安吉拉。
How do we like Michael's drink? It is refreshing. Oh, that's wonderful. Oh, that's wonderful. I know. I know. I'm here for it. Guys, what do you think? Right. Ooh, it's really nice. It's really nice. I was expecting a cringe and there's no cringe. According to the Kahlua website, it is made with two ounces of Kahlua to three ounces
我们喜欢迈克尔的饮料吗？它很提神。哦，太棒了。哦，太棒了。我知道。我知道。我支持它。伙计们，你们觉得呢？对。哦，真的很不错。真的很不错。我本以为会很尴尬，但一点也不尴尬。根据卡鲁阿网站的数据，它是用两盎司卡鲁阿酒加上三盎司
of milk and it has approximately 518 calories per glass. Oh my gosh. I mean, it seems like a shocking amount of calories for this refreshing drink. They also incidentally, on the Kahlua website, I noticed they had a drink called the Orange Blonde. And it really reminded me of Jim and Pam's drink of Baileys and orange juice. Because the photo on the website, it's not selling the Orange Blonde very well. It looks like that curdled drink that we drank before. But I don't know. I didn't bring the ingredients for that one.
牛奶制成的，每杯大约含有518卡路里。噢，天哪。我是说，对于这种清爽的饮料来说，这卡路里数量真是惊人。顺便说一句，我在卡鲁阿网站上还注意到他们有一种叫“橙色金发女郎”的饮料。这真的让我想起了吉姆和帕姆的贝诗丽（Baileys）加橙汁饮料。因为网站上的照片，它把“橙色金发女郎”推销得不太好。它看起来就像我们以前喝过的那种凝固的饮料。不过我不知道。我没有带那款饮料的原料。
I don't even know why I'm bringing it up. I'm okay to pass on the Orange Blonde. When you said Orange Blonde, I just thought of like those summers when I was lifeguarding as a teenager and we put a whole bunch of sun in our hair and we all like these orange blondes. Well, Jenna and Sam made this Kahlua sombrero and it's so good. I Googled it. I didn't even know if it was a real drink and I looked it up. Here's one thing I found that I thought was interesting. A lot of these types of drinks became popular during prohibition. Oh.
我都不知道我为什么要提起这个。我可以直接跳过“橙色金发女郎”。当你说“橙色金发女郎”时，我脑子里就想起了我十几岁当救生员的那些夏天，我们在头发上喷了一大堆防晒喷雾，我们都成了这种橙色金发女郎。好吧，珍娜和萨姆做了这款卡鲁阿咖啡甜酒，真的很好喝。我用谷歌查了一下。我甚至不知道它是不是一款真正的饮料，我查了查。以下是我发现的一个我觉得很有趣的事情。很多这类饮料是在禁酒令期间流行起来的。哦。
According to the internet, cocktail fans had to get creative. In this case, people that liked brandy or whiskey, they could camouflage their drinks with milk and it was harder to detect the alcohol. Yeah. Lady, can I make an observation? What? When you do your deep dives, it just tickles me each time. It's one of my favorite things you do.
根据互联网的说法，鸡尾酒迷们不得不发挥创意。在这种情况下，喜欢白兰地或威士忌的人可以用牛奶来掩盖他们的饮料，这样更难被察觉到酒精成分。是的。女士，我能发表个观察吗？什么？当你进行深入探讨时，每次都把我逗乐。这是你做的我最喜欢的事情之一。
What do I say according to the internet? Yes, you credit the entire internet. Not a specific website. Just the whole internet says this thing and it just every time, I love it. Well, I usually look at a few different sources. I just credit the whole shebang. Well, Michael is going to meet a stranger who's also having a drink at the bar. They're going to strike up a little conversation and become fast friends. I thought this toast was one of the best toasts I'd ever heard and since we're drinking a Kahlua sombrero together, we've got to hear Michael and D'Angelo's toast.
我是怎么说的，根据互联网？是的，你致谢了整个互联网。不是某个特定的网站。只是整个互联网这么说，每次我都觉得很有趣。好吧，我通常会看几个不同的来源。我只是致谢了整个大杂烩。好吧，迈克尔要遇到一个同样在酒吧喝酒的陌生人。他们将展开一段小对话，并迅速成为朋友。我觉得这个祝酒词是我听过的最好的祝酒词之一，既然我们正在一起喝卡鲁阿咖啡甜酒，我们就必须听听迈克尔和德安吉洛的祝酒词。
Leaving my company after 19 years. I'll drink to that. I'm starting at a company this week. Oh, really? To beginnings and endings. And to middles, the unsung heroes. And to moms. The moms of the troops. That's right. They are going to drink to beginnings, endings, middles. The unsung heroes.
在公司工作了19年后离开。我为这个干杯。我这周要开始在一家公司上班。哦，真的吗？为了开始与结束。还有中间阶段，无名英雄。还有妈妈们。军队的妈妈们。没错。他们要为开始、结束、中间阶段干杯。无名英雄。
Moms and the troops. Cheers. They got it all. They go on to discuss the fact that Michael is moving to Colorado, you know, the Sunshine State. It's actually the Centennial State. Florida is the Sunshine State. It would be funny if through this whole scene, there was just like, eh, every time they got something wrong. I know.
妈妈们和军队。干杯。他们把什么都包了。他们接着讨论迈克尔要搬到科罗拉多州的事，你知道的，阳光之州。实际上那是百年之州。佛罗里达州才是阳光之州。如果在这整场戏中，每次他们说错什么时都有那种“呃”的声音，那就好玩了。我知道。
Because then D'Angelo says, don't mess with Colorado. Instead of don't mess with Texas. Yes. That's amazing. Sonny Bobo. Michael doesn't want to end up like him. And it turns out they both really love the Summer Olympics. I loved it when they were like, try the Luge once. Never go back.
因为接着德安吉洛说，别惹科罗拉多。而不是别惹德克萨斯。是的。这太棒了。桑尼·博博。迈克尔不想落得和他一样的下场。结果证明他们两个都非常喜欢夏季奥运会。我最喜欢他们说，尝试一次雪橇。就再也回不去了。
Yeah. The scene would have continued, Jenna. There's a whole montage of them hanging out all night. I want you to hear a little bit of it first. Like hanging out before they realize who they are? No, hanging out before they go to the office. Oh, I see. There was a lot more hanging out and it culminates with them going to see Dunder Mifflin. But I want to play a little bit of it. First of all, they decide to do shots. We see a
是的，珍娜，这个场景本会继续下去。有一整段他们整晚闲逛的蒙太奇。我想让你先听听其中的一小部分。就像在认出彼此之前闲逛？不，在去办公室之前闲逛。哦，我明白了。有很多闲逛，最后以他们去看邓德米夫林告终。但我想播放一小段。首先，他们决定喝烈酒。我们看到了
little bit of that, but the scene would have continued. I have heard that it is impossible to become addicted to vodka. That is true. That is true. Vodka is non-addictive. Most of the higher spirits are undetected. That is because of the potato. One, two, three, to new friends. Wow. Wow. This is going to take hours. Neither of them could drink the whole shot. They just barely took a sip and they were both like, ugh. And then there's a montage of them playing a video game. In the background, you might
一小部分，但这个场景本会继续下去。我听说喝伏特加是不可能上瘾的。这是真的。这是真的。伏特加是不会上瘾的。大多数高度烈酒都是察觉不到的。那是因为马铃薯。一，二，三，敬新朋友。哇。哇。这要花好几个小时。他们俩谁也没能把整杯烈酒喝完。他们只是勉强抿了一口，然后两人都说，呃。接着是一段他们玩电子游戏的蒙太奇。在背景中，你可能
have seen of this scene. It looked like I thought it was an ATM machine. There's actually a whole scene of them playing a game called Photo Hunt on it. Then they eat hot wings and bruschetta and then they end up at the swimming pool of the hotel and they have a whole conversation about the onion, the magazine, the onion. Oh, uh-huh. And let's hear that. Because one day they say that blueberries prevent cancer and then the next day they say that blueberries cause cancer. That's totally true. You know what would be a great onion headline? Cancer prevents cancer. That's so onion. It's so you, but it's also so onion.
会看到这个场景。看起来像是一台自动取款机。实际上有一整场戏是他们在上面玩一个叫“寻找照片”的游戏。然后他们吃辣鸡翅和意式烤面包，最后他们来到了酒店的游泳池，他们就洋葱、杂志、洋葱展开了一场谈话。哦，嗯哼。让我们听听那个。因为有一天他们说蓝莓能防癌，然后第二天他们又说蓝莓致癌。这绝对是真的。你知道什么会是一个很好的洋葱新闻标题吗？癌症预防癌症。太洋葱了。太像你了，但也太洋葱了。
Are they like in a swimming pool while they're having that conversation? They're at water. Yeah, they're sitting next to the swimming pool and they're just kind of like flipping their hands in the water, you know? I see. So tickled by each other, that snort laugh cracked me up. I went to the script. It was totally scripted, but if you watch it, you can see them acting like laughing and then they just, the two of them just both start laughing. Right. Well, I do want to give a shout out to our bartender played by Casey Washington
他们是在游泳池里进行那段谈话吗？他们在水边。是的，他们坐在游泳池旁边，然后只是把手在水里拨来拨去，你知道的？我明白了。彼此逗乐，那个喷鼻息的笑声把我逗乐了。我查看了剧本。这完全是写在剧本里的，但如果你看的话，你能看到他们先是在装作笑，然后他们两个就突然都开始笑了起来。对的。好吧，我要向我们的酒保卡西·华盛顿致敬，
and give you a little location alert. At the beginning of this episode, you see an exterior shot of a hotel that is actually a shot of the Scranton Hotel, but we filmed this episode at the Universal Sheridan on Lancashire in North Hollywood, California. So Angela, we had a fan question from Cassandra A. and Victoria, British Columbia. How much of Will and Steve's dialogue was improvised? You mentioned all that stuff by the pool was scripted. Was this pretty much scripted? I would say so. I mean, it's kind of hard to tell because you have the extended cut and then you have the episode that aired and then in the shooting draft, there were one
并给你一个小外景提醒。在这集的开头，你看到一个酒店的外景镜头，那实际上是斯克兰顿酒店的镜头，但我们是在加利福尼亚州北好莱坞兰开夏大街的环球喜来登酒店拍摄这一集的。所以安吉拉，我们收到了来自不列颠哥伦比亚省维多利亚市卡桑德拉·A的粉丝提问。威尔和史蒂夫的台词有多少是即兴发挥的？你提到池边那些内容都是剧本写的。这些基本上都是按剧本演的吗？我想是的。我是说，这有点难说，因为你有加长版，然后你有播出的版本，在拍摄初稿中，有
or two discrepancies. So you can see where they probably went off book here or there, but it was very scripted what you're seeing almost word for word pause for pause. Wow. Well, this is all going to lead them to Dunder Mifflin. Michael is going to show D'Angelo the office late at night. Oh, yeah. D'Angelo is so excited to see it. He says this will do just fine. And then D'Angelo is going to have his first talking head. Yeah. He's going to say he's looking forward to tomorrow. And then Michael jumps up from
一两处不一致的地方。所以你能看出他们在哪里可能偶尔脱离剧本，但你看到的几乎是逐字逐句、停顿对停顿的剧本内容。哇。好吧，这一切都将引导他们来到邓德米夫林。迈克尔要在深夜向德安吉洛展示办公室。哦，是的。德安吉洛看到它时兴奋极了。他说这样就行了。然后德安吉洛将迎来他的第一个访谈镜头。是的。他说他很期待明天。然后迈克尔从
underneath and they're like, did that just happen? And they start to chase each other and they're like, we should make a movie. You guys, they've had an evening of drinking. A lot of that got cut out. So this talking head is making a lot more sense to me now that you filled in the blanks, Angela. Not only that, but their first day at Dunder Mifflin would have started with Michael asleep on the couch. They literally stayed there overnight. What? Yes.
下面跳出来，他们说，刚刚发生什么了？然后他们开始追逐对方，他们说，我们应该拍个电影。伙计们，他们经历了一个晚上的饮酒狂欢。很多内容都被剪掉了。所以安吉拉，听了你的补充，这个访谈镜头现在对我来说更有意义了。不仅如此，他们第一天在邓德米夫林本来应该以迈克尔在沙发上睡着开始。他们 literalmente 在那里过夜了。什么？是的。
Yeah. And D'Angelo comes in in the morning with some coffees. This is how the scenes at Dunder Mifflin would have started. Rise and shine, coffee time. Do not talk to me until I have had my coffee. Until I've had my coffee. Do not talk to me. Oh, I feel better. I feel awesome. It does not agree with me. Coffee. No.
是的，德安吉洛早上带着一些咖啡进来了。邓德米夫林的场景本来是这样开始的。起床啦，喝咖啡时间到。在我喝咖啡之前不要跟我说话。在我喝咖啡之前。不要跟我说话。哦，我感觉好多了。我感觉棒极了。它不合我的胃口。咖啡。不。
And yet I have to have it. You know what? Coffee keeps me regular. Yeah. That's the best time of the day in that regard. Right, right, right. That is the best time of the day. Right, right, right. I get her about seven minutes.
然而我不得不喝它。你知道吗？咖啡能让我保持规律。是的。在这方面这是一天中最美好的时间。对，对，对。那是一天中最美好的时间。对，对，对。我大约七分钟。
Really? Yep. Seven minutes from this. B-line. So at 8.37. Well, this scene would have gone on to Oscar in the parking lot, and then there was another scene, Jenna. Pam and Jim are arriving to work, and Pam sits down to her computer and is like, what's this? And Michael's like, oh, ignore that. It's a screenplay. And Pam reads off her computer.
真的吗？是的。距离这个。直线距离。所以8点37分。好吧，这个场景本来会继续到停车场里的奥斯卡，然后还有另一个场景，珍娜。帕姆和吉姆来上班，帕姆在电脑前坐下，说，这是什么？迈克尔说，哦，别管那个。是个剧本。帕姆从电脑上读出来。
The Adventure Pals by D'Angelo Vickers and Michael Scott. And then she scrolls and goes, oh my, it's 150 pages long. They spent all night writing their screenplay? Uh-huh. Oh, I would give anything to read that. The Adventure Pals. Right after the scene of Pam discovering the Adventure Pals, Kevin enters wearing his toupee.
《冒险伙伴》，作者：德安吉洛·维克斯和迈克尔·斯科特。然后她往下滚动说，噢，天哪，有150页长。他们花了一整晚写剧本？嗯哼。哦，我愿意付出一切来读读那个。《冒险伙伴》。就在帕姆发现《冒险伙伴》的场景之后，凯文戴着假发进来了。
It says in the shooting draft, he winks to camera. Hmm, it's feeling sassy today. Well, he picked a good day to wear his toupee. Maybe did we all know that we were going to meet our new manager today? Was that a thing? We must have, because Michael's going to make an announcement. He's standing in front of his office. The blinds are drawn.
拍摄初稿里写着，他对镜头眨了眨眼。嗯，今天感觉挺时髦的。好吧，他选了个好日子戴假发。也许我们都知道今天要见新经理吗？那是真的吗？我们一定知道，因为迈克尔要宣布个消息。他站在办公室前面。百叶窗拉上了。
He asks everyone for a round of applause. Then he introduces D'Angelo. D'Angelo's speech is so hilarious when he talks about just himself, when he's like, I'm as comfortable at a ball game as I am at the opera. The speech would have continued. We would have learned more about him. Yes, Angela, I had to know if there was more to this, and I also went to the script.
他请大家鼓掌。然后他介绍德安吉洛。德安吉洛的演讲太搞笑了，当他只谈论自己时，当他说，我在球场上和在歌剧院里一样自在。这个演讲本会继续。我们会对有他更多了解。是的，安吉拉，我不得不去弄清楚这后面是不是还有更多内容，我也查了剧本。
I had to know. Would you like to hear it? Because we also shot it. Oh, please. I'd much rather hear it than read it. A little bit about myself. I love the American Southwest for starters. You may call them Arizona, New Mexico, Nevada, Utah.
我必须知道。你想听听吗？因为我们其实也拍了。哦，拜托。我宁愿听也不愿读。关于我自己的一点小事。首先我热爱美国西南部。你们可能叫它们亚利桑那州、新墨西哥州、内华达州、犹他州。
I call them heaven. I have a peanut allergy, something I live with. It's a part of me. I've learned to cope with it. I was a nationally ranked high jumper in high school. Really? Yeah. I didn't know that.
我叫它们天堂。我对花生过敏，这是我生活中的一部分。这是我的一部分。我学会了与它共处。我曾是高中全国排名前列的跳高运动员。真的吗？是的。我不知道。
Couldn't do it in college for academic reasons. And that's something that still bugs me. What else? Was I comfortable at a ball game as I am at the opera? I just think about the writer's room after a speech like that, and I think about them all just shouting out different quirks of DeAngelo Vickers and how much fun it must have been as a writer's room to build this character.
由于学术原因没能在大学继续。这仍然让我耿耿于怀。还有什么？我在球场上和在歌剧院里一样自在吗？我只是想到听完这样的演讲后编剧室的反应，想到他们都在大喊大叫德安吉洛·维克斯的各种古怪特质，作为编剧室来塑造这个角色一定很有趣。
Well, you know, there was another line in the script that didn't make it. That was my favorite. DeAngelo says, I've never ridden a motorcycle. I've had chances, it just doesn't interest me. And I believe with hard work, we can become the greatest office in the world. I really do.
你知道的，剧本里还有一句台词没能播出来。那是我的最爱。德安吉洛说，我从来没骑过摩托车。我有过机会，只是它不感兴趣。我相信通过努力，我们可以成为世界上最伟大的办公室。我真的这么认为。
I feel like the line that really gives me insight into this person, into DeAngelo, is that he's never ridden a motorcycle, but it's not because he hasn't had chances to ride a motorcycle. It just doesn't interest him. So it's like, what person shares their non-interests when giving an introductory speech about themselves? That's very funny.
我觉得那句真正让我深入了解这个人、深入了解德安吉洛的话是，他从来没骑过摩托车，但这并不是因为他没有骑摩托车机会。只是它不感兴趣。所以这就好像，什么人在做自我介绍演讲时会分享他没兴趣的事？这太搞笑了。
That's a great takeaway. So it would be like, what would your non-interest be in your speech? Let me think for a second. I have one. Okay, what's yours? The first thing that came to mind is like, you know what? I'm not interested in is any kind of workout
这是一个伟大的收获。所以这就好像，如果在你的演讲中，你的无兴趣点会是什么？让我想一秒钟。我有一个。好吧，你的什么？我脑子里浮现的第一件事是，你知道吗？我不感兴趣的是任何那种
that's like a boot camp. Like I don't need anyone yelling at me as I'm trying to do a push-up. That's not going to help me. It's just going to make me mad. So I've had many opportunities to do those kind of gym classes, but I'm not interested. I mean, imagine if you were introducing yourself
像训练营一样的健身。我不希望在我试着做俯卧撑时有人对我大喊大叫。那帮不了我。只会让我生气。所以我有很多机会去上那种健身课，但我没兴趣。我是说，想象一下如果你在向
to a new group of people, and that was part of your speech. Hi, I'm Angela Kinsey. I love crafting. I love my family. I don't like boot camps. I'm not interested in someone yelling at me. I understand that they can be effective, but it's not for me.
一群新的人进行自我介绍，而那是你演讲的一部分。嗨，我是安吉拉·金西。我喜欢手工。我爱我的家人。我不喜欢训练营。我对别人对我大喊大叫不感兴趣。我理解它们可能有效，但那不适合我。
And I love roller skating. Like, could you imagine if you included that in your speech about yourself? That cracks me up. I actually think it's a really wonderful way to introduce yourself. I think we should all, I'd love to note the things that people aren't interested in as well as the things
我喜欢轮滑。就像，你能想象如果在你关于自己的演讲中包含这个吗？这把我逗乐了。我其实认为这是一个非常棒的自我介绍方式。我想我们都应该，我很乐意指出人们不感兴趣的事物以及他们感兴趣的事物。
that they are interested in. I think it sort of deepens the relationship. Certainly makes speeches more interesting. Exactly. I want to go to that wedding speech. Yeah, I want to hear that groomsman's toast. Listen, we had a fan catch from Tracy G. in Albuquerque who said,
我认为这有点加深了关系。当然会让演讲更有趣。没错。我想去参加那个婚礼祝酒。是的，我想听听那个伴郎的祝酒词。听着，我们收到了来自阿尔伯克基的特雷西·G的粉丝抓包，他说，
I think I noticed the return of Meredith's designer vest in this episode. Oh, yeah. Yes, Tracy, you did. It's back. At four minutes, 34 seconds. Kate is wearing that like $250 designer vest that I wore once to a publicity event for NBC.
我想我注意到梅雷迪思的设计师背心在这集中回归了。哦，是的。是的，特雷西，你确实注意到了。它回来了。在第四分钟34秒。凯特穿着那件价值大约250美元的设计师背心，我曾为NBC的一个宣传活动穿过一次。
You know what, they got their money out of that vest because Meredith has worn it now so many times. Sure has. We also had a fan question from Megan S. in Troy, Ohio, who said at six minutes and 43 seconds, Michael is introducing D'Angelo and asks everyone to start clapping. Andy claps right away.
你知道吗，他们把那件背心的钱赚回来了，因为梅雷迪思现在穿了它好多次。确实如此。我们还收到了来自俄亥俄州特洛伊市梅根·S的粉丝提问，他说在第六分钟43秒，迈克尔在介绍德安吉洛，并请大家开始鼓掌。安迪立刻鼓掌。
Dwight and Phyllis join in shortly thereafter, although Dwight stops clapping once D'Angelo is revealed. And eventually everyone in the scene claps except for Stanley. Was this moment choreographed, scripted, or was the cast told to just clap in character? Megan, we all just did what we thought our characters would do, but after reading your fan question, I watched the scene.
德怀特和菲利斯紧随其后加入，尽管德怀特在德安吉洛露出真容后停止了鼓掌。最终场景中的每个人都鼓掌了，除了斯坦利。这一刻是精心设计的、写在剧本里的，还是剧组被告知只要按角色鼓掌就行？梅根，我们只是做了我们认为我们的角色会做的事，但在读了你的粉丝提问后，我看了这个场景。
And man, it's really fun to see how everyone decided to clap. It's so, like, it's such a little thing, but we all did it in our character's way. And it's really rich and delicious. Thank you for pointing it out. Oh, I'm going to go back and rewatch it. I love moments like that. Well, everyone in the office definitely has different
天哪，看大家决定如何鼓掌真的很有趣。这真的是一件小事，但我们都以自己角色的方式做到了。而且非常丰富、美妙。谢谢你指出来。哦，我要回去重温一下。我喜欢这样的时刻。好吧，办公室里的每个人对德安吉洛的到来
reactions to D'Angelo being there. Dwight is devastated. All of his hopes and dreams of being the manager are gone, and he really has put the time in 11 years. Kelly, on the other hand, sees the opportunity for romance. Oh, my gosh. She walks in, drops her folders in front of D'Angelo, takes her hair clip out, shakes her hair all around.
绝对有不同的反应。德怀特心碎了。他成为经理的所有希望和梦想都破灭了，他确实投入了11年的时间。另一方面，凯莉看到了浪漫的机会。噢，天哪。她走进来，把文件夹扔在德安吉洛面前，取下发夹，把头发甩来甩去。
She does a classic hair toss. She takes her glasses off and bites the stem of her glasses. And then she has a talking head where she says, that's what you call a meet cute. It got me curious, D'Angelo, about meet cutes. And, well, you know, a meet cute is a common scene found in romantic comedies in which the love interests meet for the first time.
她做了一个经典的甩头动作。她摘下眼镜，咬着眼镜腿。然后她有一个访谈镜头，她说，这就叫浪漫邂逅。这让我很好奇，德安吉洛，关于浪漫邂逅。嗯，你知道，浪漫邂逅是浪漫喜剧中常见的一个场景，男女主角第一次相遇。
The term meet cute was an accidental phrase coined by a German-American film director named Ernst Lubitsch. He used the phrase to describe a scene in the 1938 film Bluebeard's Eighth Wife. That's the name of the movie. It's not about pirates. It's a romantic comedy starring Claudette Colbert and Gary Cooper, and they meet in a store
“浪漫邂逅”（meet cute）这个词是一个德裔美国电影导演恩斯特·刘別谦（Ernst Lubitsch）创造的一个偶然短语。他用这个短语来描述1938年电影《蓝胡子的第八个妻子》中的一个场景。那是电影的名字。它不是关于海盗的。这是一部由克劳黛·考尔贝尔和加里·库珀主演的浪漫喜剧，他们在商店里购买睡衣时相遇。
while shopping for pajamas. And it's his Eighth Wife? I don't know. I don't know if she becomes his Eighth Wife. I'm not sure who Bluebeard is. I really just concentrated on the meet cute. My aunt Thelma had eight husbands. What?
这是他的第八个妻子？我不知道。我不知道她是否成了他的第八个妻子。我不确定谁是蓝胡子。我真的只专注于浪漫邂逅。我的塞尔玛阿姨有八个丈夫。什么？
And my mom said to her one time, she was just kind of making a joke. She goes, all my exes live in Texas. And my aunt Thelma said, Bertie Jo, I don't appreciate that. Every single one of my divorces felt like a death. And I'd appreciate it if you don't joke about it. And my mom was like, and I was in the car with my mom. And I just had this moment.
我妈妈有一次对她说，她只是在开玩笑。她说，我所有的前任都住在德克萨斯。我的塞尔玛阿姨说，伯蒂·乔，我不喜欢那样。我的每一次离婚都感觉像是一场死亡。如果你们不拿这个开玩笑，我会很感激的。我妈妈当时，我当时和我妈妈在车里。我当时就有了那种时刻。
I think it was like 12 where I was like, damn. Like that was like, aunt Thelma just shut mom down. Did your mom go to all the weddings? What are you thinking when you're at like the sixth one? I don't know. I don't know. Aunt Thelma was an amazing woman. She was like really a career headstrong gal.
我想我大概12岁，当时想，天哪。这就好像，塞尔玛阿姨把妈妈噎回去了。你妈妈去参加了所有的婚礼吗？当你在第六次婚礼现场时，你在想什么？我不知道。我不知道。塞尔玛阿姨是个了不起的女人。她真的像是一个雷厉风行的职业女性。
Maybe they couldn't keep up with her. It sounds like it. She also sold insurance, but she also had two albums that got played on the radio. Oh my gosh. She wrote a song called, I'm an all-American girl. Gonna tell it like it is. Do we have an audio clip?
也许他们跟不上她的步伐。听起来是这样。她还卖保险，但她也有两张在收音机里播放过的专辑。噢，天哪。她写过一首歌叫《我是个纯正的美国女孩》。要实话实说。我们有音频剪辑吗？
I mean, we can get one. My aunt Thelma's passed away, but I love that we're still talking about her because she was bigger than life. Well, I'd love to hear an audio clip of her song. So we're going to need to get that and honor her. I would love that. Let me text my uncle Jack. Well, while we're waiting, I have an audio clip of the meat
我是说，我们可以弄到一个。我的塞尔玛阿姨已经去世了，但我喜欢我们还在谈论她，因为她比生命还要伟大。好吧，我很想听听她歌曲的音频剪辑。所以我们需要弄到一个来纪念她。我很愿意。让我给我杰克叔叔发个短信。好吧，在我们等待的时候，我有一段《蓝胡子の第八个妻子》中浪漫邂逅的音频剪辑。加里·库珀在买睡衣。他只想买睡衣的上衣。
cute in bluebeard's eighth wife. Gary Cooper is shopping for pajamas. He only wants to purchase the top of the pajamas. Not the bottom? He doesn't want the bottom. I don't know why. Sam, is that a Burning Man thing? That's a Burning Man thing.
不要裤子？他不要裤子。我不知道为什么。萨姆，那是火人节（Burning Man）的风格吗？那是火人节的风格。
Why are you asking me this? It's no bottoms. That's what I've heard. You can't wear bottoms at Burning Man? You can, but I think some fellas don't. It's a thing. I've read about it. No bottoms?
你为什么问我这个？那是没有裤子的。我听说过这个。火人节不能穿裤子吗？你可以穿，但我想有些家伙不穿。这是个风俗。我读到过。没有裤子？
No bottoms. No bottoms. What's your regret coming in? Nude on the bottom? Full nudity? That is a thing. I knew it. I've heard about it.
没有裤子。没有裤子。你来这里的遗憾是什么？下面赤裸？全裸？那是真的。我知道。我听说过。
Full nudity on the bottom? Yeah. It's got a term. Shirt cocking or something? Shirt cocking, they also call it poo-bearing. Like poo-bear. Yeah, poo-bear. Mm-hmm.
下面全裸？是的。这有个术语。叫“露恤”（shirt cocking）还是什么的？“露恤”，他们也叫它“小熊维尼”（poo-bearing）。就像小熊维尼。是的，小熊维尼。嗯哼。
Poo-bear. Okay. I guess also Donald Duck. I don't know why I knew that. It's somehow like I stumbled across an article about Burning Man, but well, Gary Cooper wants to poo-bear and only wear the top of his pajamas, and the guys in the shop will not sell the pajamas that way, so Claudette Colbert walks up and says all by the bottoms.
小熊维尼。好的。我想还有唐老鸭。我不知道我为什么知道这个。就好像我无意中看到了关于火人节的一篇文章，好吧，加里·库珀想要像小熊维尼一样只穿睡衣上衣，店里的伙计不肯那样卖睡衣，于是克劳黛·考尔贝尔走过去说，我买裤子。
Oh! Mm-hmm. She says I could use some bottoms only. So here is the audio clip. Monsieur, the management feels that to sell a pair of pajamas without the trousers would create a precedent, and the consequences might prove disastrous. Now, our president says we've had enough trouble in Europe
哦！嗯哼。她说我只需要几条裤子。所以这里是音频剪辑。先生，管理层认为，在没有裤子的前提下出售一副睡衣会开创一个先例，其后果可能会是灾难性的。现在，我们的总统说我们在欧洲已经有足够的麻烦了
as it is, and he wonders if he would be kind enough to look at the selection of straw hats. You tell your president that if I can't buy pajamas without the trousers, I'll... I'll buy the trousers. Yes, I may buy the trousers. How do you do? How do you do, madame?
正如它所展现的，他想知道他是否愿意好心看看草帽的选择。你告诉你们总统，如果我不能在没有裤子的情况下买睡衣，我将……我将买裤子。是的，我可能会买裤子。你好吗？你好，夫人。
How do you do, madame? How do you do? I'm looking for pajamas for a gentleman, and for his purpose, the trousers are enough. A very fortunate solution. Yeah, it certainly is. Provided we can agree on the color and the pattern, of course. Oh, how about this blue pair?
你好，夫人。你好吗？我在为一个绅士寻找睡衣，为了他的目的，裤子就足够了。一个非常幸运的解决方案。是的，当然是的。前提是我们在颜色和图案上达成一致，当然。哦，这双蓝色的怎么样？
Oh, heavens know it's too dark. I like to see something gay in the morning, don't you? Not too darn gay. There's not a laugh in me before breakfast. Oh, you should try to brighten up your life. Now, let's see. How about this one? Stripes. I hate stripes.
哦，天哪，太深了。我喜欢早上看到一些欢快的东西，不是吗？不太该死的欢快。我吃早饭前一点笑意也没有。哦，你应该试着让你的生活更明亮一些。现在，让我们看看。这个怎么样？条纹。我讨厌条纹。
Oh, now, that's funny. When I was standing at the other counter, I was watching you. You were? Oh, I hope you don't mind. Not a bit. Well, I said to myself, now, if I had to select pajamas for that gentleman, what would I choose?
哦，那太有趣了。当我站在另一个柜台时，我在看着你。你在看我？哦，希望你不在意。一点也不。好吧，我对自己说，现在，如果我必须为那位绅士挑选睡衣，我会选什么？
And let me tell you, if ever there was a stripey type, it's you. It's a no. Why don't you try it on? What do you think? Stunning. These things are so loud, I'd hear them in the dark. I have enough trouble getting to sleep.
我告诉你，如果曾经有过条纹控的话，那就是你。不要。你为什么不试穿一下？你觉得怎么样？惊艳。这些东西太吵了，我在黑暗中都能听到它们的声音。我入睡已经够困难的了。
Oh, you don't look like a martyr to insomnia. Really, it's no joke. I don't sleep well. Surely you can't blame it on the pajamas. I guess you're right. It's probably the climate. Now, don't blame it on the Riviera. I resent that. We have the best climate in the world here, and we're very proud of it. I'm sorry. I don't want to hurt your feeling, but I don't sleep. Maybe you should see a doctor.
哦，你看上去不像个失眠症烈士。真的，这不是个笑话。我睡不好。你当然不能把这归咎于睡衣。我想你是对的。可能时气候问题。现在，别把责任推给里维埃拉。我对此很生气。我们这里拥有世界上最好的气候，我们为此感到自豪。对不起。我不想伤害你的感情，但我也睡不着。也许你应该去看医生。
By the way, how many pillows do you use? None. Did you ever try putting two pillows under your feet? No. Don't do it. It's very bad. Oh, do you know what might help you? The method of Professor Urganzef. What's that?
顺便问一下，你用几个枕头？不用。你试过把两个枕头放在脚下吗？没有。别那样做。非常糟糕。哦，你知道什么可能会有帮助吗？乌尔根泽夫教授的方法。那是什么？
Well, you take a long word like Czechoslovakia, for instance, and you spell it backwards. I can't even spell it forward. Try it just once. As you spell it backwards, you stretch and yawn between each letter, or you drift off in no time. Sounds swell. You'll take the stripes?
好吧，你取一个长词，比如捷克斯洛伐克，然后你倒着拼写它。我连正着拼都不会。试一次就好。当你倒着拼写时，你在每个字母之间伸展和打哈欠，或者你很快就会飘然入睡。听起来棒极了。你要买条纹的吗？
I'll take the stripes. I love it so much. I want to see the whole movie. There's so much to unpack in that audio clip. Gary Cooper is a real stick in the mud, except he wants to wear pajama tops only. But otherwise, he can't sleep. He doesn't use a pillow.
我要买条纹的。我太喜欢了。我想看整部电影。这段音频剪辑里有太多值得剖析的东西了。加里·库珀真是个老古板，除了他只想穿睡衣上衣。但除此之外，他睡不着。他不用枕头。
He doesn't like to laugh in the mornings. There's so much. So much. I just love that she says, whatever you do, don't blame it on the Riviera. No. It's so amazing. Also, though, the guy doesn't want to sell him just the tops only
他不喜欢在早上笑。有太多了。太多了。我太喜欢她说的那句，无论你做什么，都不要把责任推给里维埃拉。不。太棒了。不过还有，那家伙不想只卖给他上衣
because the guy is like, what will this start? You know what it starts? Burning Man. Apparently. I mean, the guy was right. If we start selling pajama tops only. Pajamas separate. We're going to get to Burning Man, and it happened.
因为那家伙说，这会开创什么先例？你知道这开创了什么吗？火人节。显然。我是说，那家伙是对的。如果我们开始只卖睡衣上衣。睡衣分开卖。我们将去参加火人节，而这确实发生了。
So he was correct. After finding this clip, I felt compelled to Google Best Movie Meat Cutes Ever. Oh, yeah. There are so many lists, so many articles. I went down a rabbit hole watching Meat Cutes. I highly recommend this if you need a boost in your mood. Just Google Meat Cutes.
所以他是对的。找到这段剪辑后，我忍不住在谷歌上搜索了“史上最佳电影浪漫邂逅”。哦，是的。有那么多的列表，那么多的文章。我陷入了观看浪漫邂逅的兔子洞。如果你需要提振心情，我强烈推荐这个。只需谷歌搜索“浪漫邂逅”。
Is there like a link? Is there like a compilation on YouTube or something? I didn't find any compilations because I was going through the articles and I would just see the movie and then I would try to search for that Meat Cute. Mm-hmm. Some of the top ones were when Harry met Sally. Mm-hmm.
Is there like a link? Is there like a compilation on YouTube or something? I didn't find any compilations because I was going through the articles and I would just see the movie and then I would try to search for that Meat Cute. Mm-hmm. Some of the top ones were when Harry met Sally. Mm-hmm.|||这里有个链接吗？YouTube上有没有类似合辑之类的东西？我没找到什么合辑，因为我当时在翻看那些文章，看到某部电影后，就会试着去搜索那个“初次相遇”（Meat Cute）。嗯哼。其中排名前几的就有《当哈利遇到莎莉》。嗯哼。
Moonstruck. Oh. I love Moonstruck. It's one of my favorites. House Stella got her groove back. Oh, yeah. Also delicious. Uh-huh.
Moonstruck. Oh. I love Moonstruck. It's one of my favorites. House Stella got her groove back. Oh, yeah. Also delicious. Uh-huh.|||《月色撩人》。哦。我超爱《月色撩人》。这是我的最爱之一。《斯特拉怎么了》（How Stella Got Her Groove Back）。哦，对。也很带感。呃哼。
The big sick. There were so many. I could go on and on, but do yourself a favor. If you ever need a mood boost, watch some Meat Cutes. Speaking of some uplifting stuff, here is my anthelma song. I found it. All American Girl. Yay!
The big sick. There were so many. I could go on and on, but do yourself a favor. If you ever need a mood boost, watch some Meat Cutes. Speaking of some uplifting stuff, here is my anthelma song. I found it. All American Girl. Yay!|||《大病一场》。这类电影太多了。我可以一直说下去，但答应我，如果你什么时候需要振奋一下心情，就去看点“初次相遇”桥段。说到这些让人心情大好的东西，这是我的“安塞尔玛”之歌。我找到了。全美女孩（All American Girl）。耶！
All American Girl. Angela, I love it so much. Mm-hmm. She has a great voice. Oh my gosh. She wrote that herself. Yes. She wrote two songs and they actually got played on the radio.
All American Girl. Angela, I love it so much. Mm-hmm. She has a great voice. Oh my gosh. She wrote that herself. Yes. She wrote two songs and they actually got played on the radio.|||《全美女孩》。安吉拉，我太喜欢这首歌了。嗯哼。她的嗓音真棒。天哪。这歌是她自己写的。对。她写了两首歌，而且真的在电台里播出了。
When it happened, when we heard her song, my whole family went crazy. Of course. It was so exciting. And she would be so tickled. You know, she's passed away, but she'd be so tickled to know that we played her song on our podcast. I'm glad we did. Me too.
When it happened, when we heard her song, my whole family went crazy. Of course. It was so exciting. And she would be so tickled. You know, she's passed away, but she'd be so tickled to know that we played her song on our podcast. I'm glad we did. Me too.|||当时事情发生时，当我们听到她的歌时，我们全家人都疯狂了。当然啦。太让人激动了。而且她一定会非常高兴的。你知道的，她已经去世了，但要是知道我们在播客里播放了她的歌，她一定会乐坏的。我很高兴我们这么做了。我也是。
Well, Michael is now going to tell the story of his Meat Cute with DeAngelo. It's a hilarious story, but no one seems to find it hilarious. In fact, Angela, you have my favorite line in the whole episode, which is, That story makes you sound stupid. I know. It was so fun to say. Well, we're going to start to see a trend in the story here because now DeAngelo is going to tell the story and everyone thinks it's hilarious.
Well, Michael is now going to tell the story of his Meat Cute with DeAngelo. It's a hilarious story, but no one seems to find it hilarious. In fact, Angela, you have my favorite line in the whole episode, which is, That story makes you sound stupid. I know. It was so fun to say. Well, we're going to start to see a trend in the story here because now DeAngelo is going to tell the story and everyone thinks it's hilarious.|||好了，迈克尔接下来要讲他和迪安杰罗的“初次相遇”故事了。这是一个极其搞笑的故事，但似乎没人觉得好笑。事实上，安吉拉，你在整集里有一句我最喜欢的台词，那就是：“那个故事显得你像个傻子。”我知道。说出这句话可真带劲。好吧，我们接下来会在这段情节里看到一个风向转变，因为现在轮到迪安杰罗讲故事了，而大家都觉得好笑极了。
They don't think it's stupid. Mm-hmm. Michael is not pleased. And Andy says, you know what? That's why I always carry a few of these around. He opens up his jacket and he has name tags ready to go with his name on them. DeAngelo thinks this is hilarious and goes, hey, funny guy. Off is funny guy.
They don't think it's stupid. Mm-hmm. Michael is not pleased. And Andy says, you know what? That's why I always carry a few of these around. He opens up his jacket and he has name tags ready to go with his name on them. DeAngelo thinks this is hilarious and goes, hey, funny guy. Off is funny guy.|||他们可不觉得这傻。嗯哼。迈克尔很不高兴。然后安迪说：“你知道吗？这就是为什么我随身带这几个东西。”他打开夹克，里面准备好了写着他名字的名牌随时待命。迪安杰罗觉得这太搞笑了，便说：“嘿，搞笑达人。奥夫是个搞笑达人。”
Oh, that's going to start a whole thing. It is also hilarious though that Andy would carry name tags around. I mean, that is hilarious. I have to say when I saw that, I thought it was kind of a brilliant idea. It's a great move. That's what you want. The first time you meet people, you want to tell them the things you're not interested in and then let them know that you have extra name tags.
Oh, that's going to start a whole thing. It is also hilarious though that Andy would carry name tags around. I mean, that is hilarious. I have to say when I saw that, I thought it was kind of a brilliant idea. It's a great move. That's what you want. The first time you meet people, you want to tell them the things you're not interested in and then let them know that you have extra name tags.|||哦，这下要引发一连串事情了。不过安迪居然随身带着名牌，这也太搞笑了。我是说，这真的滑稽。我得说当我看到那一幕时，我觉得这简直是个天才主意。这招太高了。这正是你想要的。第一次见到别人时，你得先告诉他们你对什么不感兴趣，然后再让他们知道你还有多余的名牌。
Yeah. This is changing my whole life this episode. Now Michael is going to introduce Jim and Pam. And Jim and Pam are going to talk about their baby CC. And it seems like DeAngelo is really into this idea that they have a baby because he has four kids of his own. Oh, yeah. They're very excited.
Yeah. This is changing my whole life this episode. Now Michael is going to introduce Jim and Pam. And Jim and Pam are going to talk about their baby CC. And it seems like DeAngelo is really into this idea that they have a baby because he has four kids of his own. Oh, yeah. They're very excited.|||是啊。这一集简直改变了我整个人生。现在迈克尔要介绍吉姆和帕姆了。吉姆和帕姆要谈论他们的宝宝茜茜。看起来迪安杰罗对他们有孩子这件事非常感兴趣，因为他自己就有四个孩子。哦，对。他们非常兴奋。
They see they're in. They have this Jim and Pam talking head where Jim has this line. They never talk about careers being made because of unplanned pregnancies. And I noticed an acting faux pas. What? It's on me. If you watch the talking head. Do you mouth his lines?
They see they're in. They have this Jim and Pam talking head where Jim has this line. They never talk about careers being made because of unplanned pregnancies. And I noticed an acting faux pas. What? It's on me. If you watch the talking head. Do you mouth his lines?|||他们觉得有戏了。他们有一段吉姆和帕姆的单人访谈，吉姆有这样一句台词：“人们从不谈论因意外怀孕而成就的事业。”而我注意到一个表演上的失误。什么？在我身上。如果你看那段单人访谈的话。你会跟着他的台词对口型吗？
No, I don't mouth his lines. I start laughing before Jim finishes his joke. His line is they never talk about careers that were made and then I start giggling. But he hasn't finished the rest of his sentence. I clearly, we had done the talking head so many times. That you were jumping ahead. I was jumping in with my laughter before he had finished speaking. If you watch it, it makes no sense that she would already be laughing.
No, I don't mouth his lines. I start laughing before Jim finishes his joke. His line is they never talk about careers that were made and then I start giggling. But he hasn't finished the rest of his sentence. I clearly, we had done the talking head so many times. That you were jumping ahead. I was jumping in with my laughter before he had finished speaking. If you watch it, it makes no sense that she would already be laughing.|||不，我才没有对口型。在吉姆讲完笑话之前我就开始笑了。他的台词是“他们从不谈论成就的事业”，然后我就开始咯咯笑了。但他还没把后半句说完呢。我显然——我们做过太多次单人访谈了。以至于你抢拍了。我在他话还没说完时就笑着插话了。如果你仔细看，她还没说完就已经在笑了，这根本说不通。
Anyway, acting faux pas. Faux pas. Dwight is going to lure Michael into the stairwell. And one of my favorite lines of the whole episode is coming up. Michael says, are you kidding? I'd come anywhere to see a turtle. Where'd you find him? I mean, what the hell?
Anyway, acting faux pas. Faux pas. Dwight is going to lure Michael into the stairwell. And one of my favorite lines of the whole episode is coming up. Michael says, are you kidding? I'd come anywhere to see a turtle. Where'd you find him? I mean, what the hell?|||总之，这就是表演上的失误。失误。德怀特要把迈克尔引诱到楼梯间去。整集里我最喜欢的台词之一就要出现了。迈克尔说：“你在开玩笑吧？为了看乌龟我哪儿都肯去。你在哪儿找到它的？我的天啊，搞什么鬼？”
He's so excited about a turtle. Well, there is no turtle and now Michael's annoyed because he's going to have to go watch videos of turtles. Dwight's going to ask him why Michael, you know, I mean, why wasn't I considered you were pushing for me, right? No, Michael was not pushing for him. Dwight doesn't know that yet. But he will. And it's going to break his heart. There would have been a Jim and Pam scene here where they're, you know, really going to lean into this CC bit that they're doing with D'Angelo.
He's so excited about a turtle. Well, there is no turtle and now Michael's annoyed because he's going to have to go watch videos of turtles. Dwight's going to ask him why Michael, you know, I mean, why wasn't I considered you were pushing for me, right? No, Michael was not pushing for him. Dwight doesn't know that yet. But he will. And it's going to break his heart. There would have been a Jim and Pam scene here where they're, you know, really going to lean into this CC bit that they're doing with D'Angelo.|||他对一只乌龟这么兴奋。好吧，根本没有什么乌龟，现在迈克尔很不爽，因为他得去看乌龟的视频了。德怀特要问他为什么，迈克尔，你知道的，我是说，为什么没考虑我？你当时在为我争取对吧？不，迈克尔根本没有为他争取。德怀特现在还不知道这一点。但他马上就会知道了。而且这会让他心碎。这里本来应该有一场吉姆和帕姆的戏，他们会在戏里，你知道的，顺着他们对迪安杰罗演的那出关于茜茜的戏码继续发挥。
And it really shows how all of this starts to build. I want you to hear it. D'Angelo, you'll get a kick out of this. Do you know those old school blocks, the wooden blocks for kids? Oh my gosh, yes. Oh, yeah, the block story. This is great. Right.
And it really shows how all of this starts to build. I want you to hear it. D'Angelo, you'll get a kick out of this. Do you know those old school blocks, the wooden blocks for kids? Oh my gosh, yes. Oh, yeah, the block story. This is great. Right.|||这真的展现了这一切是如何开始发酵的。我想让你们听听这个。迪安杰罗，你一定会觉得这很有意思。你知道那种老式的积木吗，就是给小孩子玩的木质积木？噢天哪，知道。哦，对，积木的故事。这太棒了。没错。
Okay, go ahead. So the blocks with the letters. There's a lot. Yes. Okay. So we give a set of those to CC and we turn around for like a second. A second. And we turn back and she has spelled out the word ass in the blocks.
Okay, go ahead. So the blocks with the letters. There's a lot. Yes. Okay. So we give a set of those to CC and we turn around for like a second. A second. And we turn back and she has spelled out the word ass in the blocks.|||好吧，说下去。就是那种带字母的积木。有很多块。是的。好吧。于是我们把一套积木给茜茜玩，然后我们转身大概就一秒钟。就一秒钟。等我们转过头来，她居然用积木拼出了“混蛋”（ass）这个词。
So we're laughing. She's grinning. It was so funny. It's our riot. They really do say the darnedest things. So D'Angelo is just looking at you guys with like this blank expression. And then Stanley's like, oh, maybe I need to chime in here on the kid thing. Maybe the kid thing is working.
So we're laughing. She's grinning. It was so funny. It's our riot. They really do say the darnedest things. So D'Angelo is just looking at you guys with like this blank expression. And then Stanley's like, oh, maybe I need to chime in here on the kid thing. Maybe the kid thing is working.|||于是我们哈哈大笑。她咧着嘴笑。太搞笑了。简直笑死我们了。小孩子真会说出些让人大跌眼镜的话。所以迪安杰罗就用那种面无表情的眼神看着你们俩。然后斯坦利就想：哦，也许我得在这聊聊养孩子的事了。也许聊孩子这招管用。
So he puts the button. But D'Angelo is just looking at you guys like, I don't know what to say to these people. I remember shooting that scene. And I just want to say I'm really impressed with me and John in this episode and our giddiness over our daughter. We did not have children yet, either of us. And I thought we really seemed like parents. I feel like we're told stories how parents do.
So he puts the button. But D'Angelo is just looking at you guys like, I don't know what to say to these people. I remember shooting that scene. And I just want to say I'm really impressed with me and John in this episode and our giddiness over our daughter. We did not have children yet, either of us. And I thought we really seemed like parents. I feel like we're told stories how parents do.|||于是他按下了按钮（插了话）。但迪安杰罗只是看着你们俩，那表情就像是：“我不知道该对这群人说些什么。”我还记得拍那场戏的时候。我只想说，我对这一集里我和约翰的表现，以及我们对女儿的那种狂热劲儿印象深刻。我们俩当时都还没有孩子。但我觉我们看起来真的很像父母。我觉得我们就像真正的父母那样讲着育儿故事。
Parents really are like so tickled by the little things that their kids do. And we had no experience with that yet. But I'm like, I think we did so good. I had to remind myself that when we shot this, we were still childless in our real lives. It's so true though. It's so true. I was once at a very, very fancy award show party and I walked up to a very well known actress and her husband.
Parents really are like so tickled by the little things that their kids do. And we had no experience with that yet. But I'm like, I think we did so good. I had to remind myself that when we shot this, we were still childless in our real lives. It's so true though. It's so true. I was once at a very, very fancy award show party and I walked up to a very well known actress and her husband.|||父母们确实很容易被孩子们做的那些小事逗乐。我们当时还没有这方面的经验。但我想说，我们演得真好。我得提醒自己，当我们拍这场戏时，我们在现实生活中都还没有孩子。不过这真的太真实了。太真实了。我曾经参加过一个非常非常高级的颁奖典礼派对，我走到一位非常知名的女演员和她丈夫面前。
I was making conversation. Isabel was only a year old. They did not have kids yet. And you guys would all know who these people are. They're very famous. And I was trying to make conversation and I told a story about Isabel and the wife sort of nodded, like, oh yeah, and the husband looked at me and said, I have a lawyer who has a kid and whenever I can't sleep, I call him and I tell him to tell me something about
I was making conversation. Isabel was only a year old. They did not have kids yet. And you guys would all know who these people are. They're very famous. And I was trying to make conversation and I told a story about Isabel and the wife sort of nodded, like, oh yeah, and the husband looked at me and said, I have a lawyer who has a kid and whenever I can't sleep, I call him and I tell him to tell me something about|||我在跟他们套近乎。伊莎贝尔当时才一岁大。他们当时还没有孩子。大家肯定都知道这些人是谁。他们非常有名。我当时试图找话题聊天，就讲了一个关于伊莎贝尔的故事，那个妻子点点头，仿佛在说：“哦，这样啊”，而那个丈夫看着我说：“我有个律师朋友有小孩，每当我失眠的时候，我就会打电话让他跟我讲讲关于|||
his kid. Oh my gosh. Yeah. And I went, you realize that privately you're going to tell me who these people are. Oh yeah, I will. Because I went, okay. And I just like slowly backed away and I thought, oh man, you're kind of a dick. You would know who this person is, he's very famous.
his kid. Oh my gosh. Yeah. And I went, you realize that privately you're going to tell me who these people are. Oh yeah, I will. Because I went, okay. And I just like slowly backed away and I thought, oh man, you're kind of a dick. You would know who this person is, he's very famous.|||他孩子的事。”哦天哪。是啊。当时我就想：“你私底下可得告诉我这些人究竟是谁。”哦对，我会的。因为当时我就想：“好吧。”然后我默默地退了开来，心想：天哪，你这人真够混蛋的。你们肯定知道这人是谁，他非常出名。
I will tell you later, Jenna. And when we do our podcast called Burn It to the Ground, I'll tell everybody. Great. Have we established on air that we're doing a podcast called Office Ladies Burn It to the Ground? No, we haven't, but I guess we just did. Someday. Our last episode ever when we're riding off into the sunset, we'll call it Burn It
I will tell you later, Jenna. And when we do our podcast called Burn It to the Ground, I'll tell everybody. Great. Have we established on air that we're doing a podcast called Office Ladies Burn It to the Ground? No, we haven't, but I guess we just did. Someday. Our last episode ever when we're riding off into the sunset, we'll call it Burn It|||我待会儿告诉你，珍娜。等我们做那个叫《将其烧为平地》（Burn It to the Ground）的播客时，我会把一切都告诉所有人。太棒了。我们在节目里定下我们要做一个叫《办公室淑女：将其烧为平地》的播客了吗？不，我们还没定，但我想我们刚刚好像已经定下来了。总有一天。等我们做到最后一期节目，我们要功成身退时，我们就叫它《将其烧为|||
to the Ground. Lady, we're going to do a whole podcast in our 60s. Oh my gosh. Called Office Ladies Burn It to the Ground. Where we just go through our list. Yeah. And we name names. Yeah, we go through our aria stark list and we just rattle it off.
to the Ground. Lady, we're going to do a whole podcast in our 60s. Oh my gosh. Called Office Ladies Burn It to the Ground. Where we just go through our list. Yeah. And we name names. Yeah, we go through our aria stark list and we just rattle it off.|||平地》。天哪，等我们到了六十岁，我们要录制一整档播客。哦天哪。就叫《办公室淑女：将其烧为平地》。我们在节目里把我们的名单挨个过一遍。对。而且我们要指名道姓。对，我们拿着艾莉亚·史塔克的复仇名单，把上面的人一吐为快。
It's going to be so fun. DeAngelo is in the break room and people are just hanging on his every word and doing everything they can to impress him. Suddenly Daryl loves the Southwest. It's one of his favorite regions. He loves the climate. This is going to lead us to my favorite scene, which is DeAngelo suggesting to Erin that she not use her name when she answers the phone.
It's going to be so fun. DeAngelo is in the break room and people are just hanging on his every word and doing everything they can to impress him. Suddenly Daryl loves the Southwest. It's one of his favorite regions. He loves the climate. This is going to lead us to my favorite scene, which is DeAngelo suggesting to Erin that she not use her name when she answers the phone.|||那一定太有趣了。迪安杰罗在休息室里，大家对他的每一句话都言听计从，并想尽一切办法给他留下好印象。突然之间，达里尔爱上了美国西南部。那是他最喜欢的地区之一。他喜欢那里的气候。这就要引出我最喜欢的一场戏了，那就是迪安杰罗建议艾琳在接电话时不要报自己的名字。
Dunder Mifflin, this is. She likes it. Then Michael's like, no, no, no, you should just do it the other way or however you want to do it. But like the other way, she's a deer in headlights, the phone rings and she just goes, I'm sorry and hangs up. This scene is so great. Will has that ability to with a smile, sort of like contradict you and I don't know how
Dunder Mifflin, this is. She likes it. Then Michael's like, no, no, no, you should just do it the other way or however you want to do it. But like the other way, she's a deer in headlights, the phone rings and she just goes, I'm sorry and hangs up. This scene is so great. Will has that ability to with a smile, sort of like contradict you and I don't know how|||“这里是邓德·米夫林。”她很喜欢这样。然后迈克尔说：“不，不，不，你应该用另一种方式，或者随你喜欢怎么做。”但换成另一种方式后，她就像被车灯照到的鹿一样惊慌失措，电话一响，她直接来了句：“对不起”然后就挂断了。这场戏太棒了。威尔有一种魔力，他能带着微笑反驳你，我真不知道他是怎么|||
he does it, but he's like, I mean, I have to manage some time, right? I think we'll change it. It's so good. By the way, I just wanted to say in this scene, you know, Erin says that the reason she answers the phone that way is because that's how Pam did it and that Pam is kind of a living legend. And we share a little smile. I would like to say that I improvised Dunder Mifflin.
he does it, but he's like, I mean, I have to manage some time, right? I think we'll change it. It's so good. By the way, I just wanted to say in this scene, you know, Erin says that the reason she answers the phone that way is because that's how Pam did it and that Pam is kind of a living legend. And we share a little smile. I would like to say that I improvised Dunder Mifflin.|||做到的，他就会说：“我的意思是，我得管理一下时间，对吧？我想我们还是改改吧。”太绝了。顺便说一句，我只想说在这场戏里，你们知道的，艾琳说她之所以那样接电话，是因为帕姆以前就是那样做的，而且帕姆某种程度上是个活着的传奇。然后我们相视一笑。我想说的是，“邓德·米夫林”是我即兴发挥的。
This is Pam on our very first shoot day. And it just kind of stuck. It was when we were doing our atmospheric work with Ken Qopis and I did it because that's how I always answered the phone when I worked in administrative jobs. I would always say like putting them investments. This is Jenna or wherever I was working Blair television. This is Jenna. Lady, you're the living legend, not Pam.
This is Pam on our very first shoot day. And it just kind of stuck. It was when we were doing our atmospheric work with Ken Qopis and I did it because that's how I always answered the phone when I worked in administrative jobs. I would always say like putting them investments. This is Jenna or wherever I was working Blair television. This is Jenna. Lady, you're the living legend, not Pam.|||“这里是帕姆”这句话出自我们的第一天拍摄日。然后这个梗就这么流传下来了。那是我们在和肯·库皮斯一起拍摄气氛镜头的时候，我这么做是因为我以前做行政工作时接电话总是这样的。我总是会说：“普特南投资公司。我是珍娜”或者无论我在哪儿工作，“布莱尔电视台。我是珍娜。”天哪，你才是活着的传奇，才不是帕姆。
I started it. It was me. There was a scene after this in the extended cut. D'Angelo is doing an aggressive jump rope workout in the conference room. He's in gym clothes. He's playing a boom box, yelling and grunting and stuff. And Michael walks in and says, I see you have found the conference room. And D'Angelo says the multi-purpose room.
I started it. It was me. There was a scene after this in the extended cut. D'Angelo is doing an aggressive jump rope workout in the conference room. He's in gym clothes. He's playing a boom box, yelling and grunting and stuff. And Michael walks in and says, I see you have found the conference room. And D'Angelo says the multi-purpose room.|||是我开创的。是我。在加长版中，后面还有一场戏。迪安杰罗正在会议室里进行高强度的跳绳锻炼。他穿着健身服。他放着手提音响，一边大喊大叫、发出哼哧哼哧的声音。然后迈克尔走进来，说道：“我看到你找到会议室了。”迪安杰罗说：“是多功能室。”
Yes, I have. That's interesting because later he's going to call a meeting in the multi-purpose room. I totally clocked it. Every little thing he does is just slightly different than the way Michael does it. Listen, I think we should take a break before we get into my second favorite scene, the shaving scene. I have fun stuff to share. Oh, so do I.
Yes, I have. That's interesting because later he's going to call a meeting in the multi-purpose room. I totally clocked it. Every little thing he does is just slightly different than the way Michael does it. Listen, I think we should take a break before we get into my second favorite scene, the shaving scene. I have fun stuff to share. Oh, so do I.|||是的，我找到了。这很有趣，因为后来他要在多功能室开会了。我完全注意到了这一点。他做的每一件小事都和迈克尔的做法有那么一点点不同。听着，我觉得在我们进入我第二喜欢的戏——刮胡子那场戏之前，我们应该休息一下。我有好玩的东西要分享。哦，我也是。
So do I. Back in a second. All right, we are back and you guys, I've got some digital clutter for you. You're bringing us back with digital clutter. I am. Guess what we were emailing about while we were filming this episode. My pregnancy. That I was pregnant.
So do I. Back in a second. All right, we are back and you guys, I've got some digital clutter for you. You're bringing us back with digital clutter. I am. Guess what we were emailing about while we were filming this episode. My pregnancy. That I was pregnant.|||我也是。马上回来。好的，我们回来了，大家伙儿，我给你们准备了一些数码杂物。你用数码杂物把我们带回节目了。是的。猜猜我们在拍摄这一集时发电子邮件都在聊什么。我的怀孕。我怀孕了。
That I was shopping for new clothes because I couldn't fit in my wardrobe. No. We were emailing about the Screen Actors Guild Awards that we had been to on January 30th of 2011. And we shot this episode in early February. And I guess we were exchanging photos from our evening. Oh my gosh, Angela. I remember what I wore.
That I was shopping for new clothes because I couldn't fit in my wardrobe. No. We were emailing about the Screen Actors Guild Awards that we had been to on January 30th of 2011. And we shot this episode in early February. And I guess we were exchanging photos from our evening. Oh my gosh, Angela. I remember what I wore.|||我因为穿不下以前的衣服而在疯狂采购新衣。不是。我们在邮件里聊的是我们2011年1月30日参加过的美国演员工会奖。我们是在2月初拍摄这一集的。我猜我们当时在互传当晚的照片。哦天哪，安吉拉。我还记得我穿的是什么。
I wore this baby blue dress that was very, it was form fitted, but it had a high neck. It was a lot of coverage, but it was very tailored. I had had the dress tailored, but by the time the event happened, I had a little poochie. I had a little belly bump and somebody wrote an article where they, oh my gosh, they hated my dress. I loved my dress. I loved it. I felt old Hollywood glam.
I wore this baby blue dress that was very, it was form fitted, but it had a high neck. It was a lot of coverage, but it was very tailored. I had had the dress tailored, but by the time the event happened, I had a little poochie. I had a little belly bump and somebody wrote an article where they, oh my gosh, they hated my dress. I loved my dress. I loved it. I felt old Hollywood glam.|||我穿了一件浅蓝色礼服，非常修身，但它是高领的。包裹得很严实，不过剪裁极其合身。我特意把这件裙子改得合身，但等到活动举行时，我已经微微有些显怀了。我挺着一个小孕肚，结果有人写了一篇文章，天哪，他们讨厌我的裙子。我可太爱我的裙子了。我爱死它了。我觉得自己有种好莱坞黄金时代的魅力。
I loved it. They hated the dress. They said that it fit me horribly, that I was like busting out of it or something. And I was mortified mostly because I was afraid that my pregnancy news was going to break. I did not realize how bumpy it was. And listen, it's not really bumpy. I mean, it's like a woman's body in a dress. Yeah.
I loved it. They hated the dress. They said that it fit me horribly, that I was like busting out of it or something. And I was mortified mostly because I was afraid that my pregnancy news was going to break. I did not realize how bumpy it was. And listen, it's not really bumpy. I mean, it's like a woman's body in a dress. Yeah.|||我超爱它。他们却讨厌那条裙子。他们说这裙子穿在我身上糟透了，说我好像要把裙子撑破了什么的。我当时感到极其尴尬，主要是因为我害怕自己怀孕的消息会曝光。我当时没意识到肚子看起来那么凸。听着，其实也不是真的很凸。我的意思是，那不过是一个穿着裙子的女性身体罢了。是啊。
Yeah. But I was afraid I was revealing something to the world that I wasn't ready to reveal. Well, let me tell you about these pictures, Jenna. To this award show, you went with your husband Lee. I took my friend Michael and I guess we had some new app where all the photos look like a Polaroid. I remember these. And they're a little blurry because these are old, old iPhones, right?
Yeah. But I was afraid I was revealing something to the world that I wasn't ready to reveal. Well, let me tell you about these pictures, Jenna. To this award show, you went with your husband Lee. I took my friend Michael and I guess we had some new app where all the photos look like a Polaroid. I remember these. And they're a little blurry because these are old, old iPhones, right?|||是啊。但我害怕自己向全世界泄露了我还不想公开的秘密。好吧，让我来跟你说说这些照片吧，珍娜。去参加这个颁奖典礼时，你是和丈夫李一起去的。我带了我的朋友迈克尔去，我猜我们当时用了什么新App，拍出来的照片看起来全都像宝丽来拍的。我记得这些。而且照片有点模糊，因为这是老得不行的iPhone拍的，对吧？
Jenna, none of these are in our book. I hadn't seen them in years. I can't even believe I found them. Do you remember how at the Screen Actors Guild Awards, we would get these giant oversized bottles of wine? Mm-hmm. They would go up to like your waist if you sat on the ground. They were like comically big.
Jenna, none of these are in our book. I hadn't seen them in years. I can't even believe I found them. Do you remember how at the Screen Actors Guild Awards, we would get these giant oversized bottles of wine? Mm-hmm. They would go up to like your waist if you sat on the ground. They were like comically big.|||珍娜，这些照片可全都不在我们的书里。我已经好多年没见过它们了。我甚至不敢相信我居然把它们找出来了。你还记得在美国演员工会奖上，我们总能拿到那种超级巨大的瓶装红酒吗？嗯哼。如果你坐在地上，它能高到你的腰部。大得简直有些滑稽。
I have a photo of Lee doing a bit with one pretending like he's pouring it. And then I have these really fun photos from our evening at our table. Jenna, oh my gosh, they made me so happy. I'll post them, but I have to show them to you right now because this photo of Lee made me laugh and brought me right back to that evening. We look beautiful. We both went for the old Hollywood glam on this one. Ready?
I have a photo of Lee doing a bit with one pretending like he's pouring it. And then I have these really fun photos from our evening at our table. Jenna, oh my gosh, they made me so happy. I'll post them, but I have to show them to you right now because this photo of Lee made me laugh and brought me right back to that evening. We look beautiful. We both went for the old Hollywood glam on this one. Ready?|||我有一张照片是李拿着其中一瓶假装在倒酒。然后我还有一些我们在桌旁度过的那个夜晚的超有趣照片。珍娜，哦天哪，它们让我太开心了。我会把它们发出来的，但我现在就得拿给你看，因为李的这张照片把我逗笑了，一下子把我拉回了那个夜晚。我们看起来太美了。我们俩这次都走了好莱坞黄金时代的复古风。准备好了吗？
I'm going to show them to you. Oh my gosh. What are these pictures? I know. I didn't find them when we were doing our book. Who knows how many more photos I have, by the way. Are we Marilyn Monroe and Jane Mansfield in these pictures? Lee looks so handsome.
I'm going to show them to you. Oh my gosh. What are these pictures? I know. I didn't find them when we were doing our book. Who knows how many more photos I have, by the way. Are we Marilyn Monroe and Jane Mansfield in these pictures? Lee looks so handsome.|||我要拿给你们看了。哦天哪。这些都是什么照片？我知道。我们做书的时候可没找到它们。顺便说一句，天知道我还藏了多少照片。我们在这些照片里简直就是玛丽莲·梦露和简·曼斯菲尔德吧？李看起来太帅了。
I know. Look at this. We are very excited to applaud for someone. You have your hands, you're like clapping high in the air. Someone got an award we were very excited about. Oh, yes. I approve. I approve of this award.
I know. Look at this. We are very excited to applaud for someone. You have your hands, you're like clapping high in the air. Someone got an award we were very excited about. Oh, yes. I approve. I approve of this award.|||我知道。你看这个。我们在为某人热烈鼓掌。你双手高高举在空中鼓掌。有人拿了个奖，我们对此激动不已。哦，是的。我批准。我批准这个奖项。
Lady, was this the one where we marched backstage to get the food? Was I so hungry because I was pregnant? Yes. This is the one where we annoyed Lawrence Fishburne. It's in our book, but these photos I only just found. Look at this one. Oh my gosh. Who are we?
Lady, was this the one where we marched backstage to get the food? Was I so hungry because I was pregnant? Yes. This is the one where we annoyed Lawrence Fishburne. It's in our book, but these photos I only just found. Look at this one. Oh my gosh. Who are we?|||小姐们，这是不是我们为了找吃的而浩浩荡荡杀到后台的那次？我是不是因为怀孕饿得不行？是的。这就是我们把劳伦斯·菲什伯恩惹烦的那次。书里有写，但这些照片我是刚找到的。看这张。哦天哪。我们俩是谁啊？
We're children. Look at one more. One more. I'm so sad these aren't in our book. I know. You tried to go through all your digital clutter. You tried. Oh my gosh.
We're children. Look at one more. One more. I'm so sad these aren't in our book. I know. You tried to go through all your digital clutter. You tried. Oh my gosh.|||我们就是小屁孩。再看一张。再看一张。没把这些收录进书里我太难过了。我知道。你已经努力翻遍所有的数码杂物了。你尽力了。哦天哪。
I'm going to post these because they really made me happy. I love them. I love them all. We look amazing. We're having the time of our lives. That's what we were emailing about this week were these blurry Polaroid photos. Well, back in the episode, D'Angelo is going to do a real boss move. He's going to have a man come and shave him in the office.
I'm going to post these because they really made me happy. I love them. I love them all. We look amazing. We're having the time of our lives. That's what we were emailing about this week were these blurry Polaroid photos. Well, back in the episode, D'Angelo is going to do a real boss move. He's going to have a man come and shave him in the office.|||我要把这些照片发出去，因为它们真的让我很开心。我太喜欢了。我全都很喜欢。我们看起来棒极了。我们正过着人生中最棒的时光。我们这周发邮件聊的就是这些模糊的宝丽来照片。好了，回到剧情中，迪安杰罗要使出真正的大佬招数了。他找了个男人来办公室给他刮胡子。
Yes. Reggie, the barber played by Stanley Ulman is going to come in with his shaving kit. Michael is going to see this and he is going to then bring his own shaving kit in and demand that Aaron shave his face. And this leads to my second favorite scene in this episode, which is this insane scene where Michael and D'Angelo are side by side in Michael's office, both getting a midday shave, one from a professional and the other from Aaron. Did you see how much shaving cream she put on his face?
Yes. Reggie, the barber played by Stanley Ulman is going to come in with his shaving kit. Michael is going to see this and he is going to then bring his own shaving kit in and demand that Aaron shave his face. And this leads to my second favorite scene in this episode, which is this insane scene where Michael and D'Angelo are side by side in Michael's office, both getting a midday shave, one from a professional and the other from Aaron. Did you see how much shaving cream she put on his face?|||没错。由斯坦利·乌尔曼饰演的理发师雷吉带着他的剃须工具箱走了进来。迈克尔看到这一幕后，也把自己的剃须工具箱拿了进来，并要求艾琳给他刮脸。这就引出了我在这一集里第二喜欢的场景——那场疯狂的戏：迈克尔和迪安杰罗并排坐在迈克尔的办公室里，两人都在大白天刮胡子，一个由专业理发师操刀，另一个则由艾琳代劳。你看到她往他脸上抹了多少剃须泡沫吗？
Reggie, I've been worried right then. I mean, it's so insane. I texted Ellie. Yeah. Because I had to know, Ellie, what was it like to do this scene? She wrote me back, Angela, and here is what she said. This is a quote, oh my God, oh my God, oh my God. That scene is up there with one of my greatest days on earth.
Reggie, I've been worried right then. I mean, it's so insane. I texted Ellie. Yeah. Because I had to know, Ellie, what was it like to do this scene? She wrote me back, Angela, and here is what she said. This is a quote, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god. That scene is up there with one of my greatest days on earth.|||雷吉，我当时就一直在担心。我是说，这太疯狂了。我给艾莉发了短信。对。因为我必须得知道，艾莉，拍这场戏是什么感觉？她回信给我了，安吉拉，她是这么说的。原话是：“我的天啊，我的天啊，我的天啊。那场戏绝对算得上是我这辈子经历过的最棒的日子之一。”
She said, she broke many times, but we have good editors, as you know. She said, I mostly just remember thinking how unbelievably lucky I was that I got to do that as my job. She said, as always, Steve was a total pro, but she absolutely remembers just getting the giggles repeatedly. And then she said this, she said, what I can't remember was, was that a real blade? It couldn't have been, right? She said, I'm pretty sure I was shaking.
She said, she broke many times, but we have good editors, as you know. She said, I mostly just remember thinking how unbelievably lucky I was that I got to do that as my job. She said, as always, Steve was a total pro, but she absolutely remembers just getting the giggles repeatedly. And then she said this, she said, what I can't remember was, was that a real blade? It couldn't have been, right? She said, I'm pretty sure I was shaking.|||她还说，她笑场了好多次，但正如你们所知，我们有优秀的剪辑师。她说，我大部分时间只记得自己当时在想，能把这个当工作我简直幸运得难以置信。她说，史蒂夫一如既往地非常专业，但她绝对记得自己一直忍不住笑场。然后她又说了这样一段话，她说：“我记不清的是，那真的是一把刀片吗？绝不可能吧？对吧？”她说：“我敢肯定我当时都在发抖。”
There's no way it was real. No way. There was not. No. Randy told me that Phil Shea took the blade out of the razor. But Angela, I remember watching that scene. I remember standing in the room and watching it, and it was so funny. Angela, I have a fan catch from Hannah L in California who said, is John Krasinski totally
There's no way it was real. No way. There was not. No. Randy told me that Phil Shea took the blade out of the razor. But Angela, I remember watching that scene. I remember standing in the room and watching it, and it was so funny. Angela, I have a fan catch from Hannah L in California who said, is John Krasinski totally|||绝对不可能是真的。不可能。根本不是。没有。兰迪告诉我，菲尔·谢伊把剃须刀里的刀片拿掉了。但安吉拉，我记得我看那场戏的时候。我记得自己就站在房间里看着，那场戏太搞笑了。安吉拉，我收到了来自加利福尼亚的粉丝汉娜·L的细节捕捉，她说：约翰·卡拉辛斯基在大家撞见艾琳给迈克尔刮脸时，是不是完全|||
breaking when everyone walks in on Aaron shaving Michael's face? And then does Mindy clock it? Yes. 100%. 100%. Yeah. And then we had a fan question from Becca H in Glasgow, Scotland who said, was the line don't shave my lips improvised by Steve?
breaking when everyone walks in on Aaron shaving Michael's face? And then does Mindy clock it? Yes. 100%. 100%. Yeah. And then we had a fan question from Becca H in Glasgow, Scotland who said, was the line don't shave my lips improvised by Steve?|||笑场了？然后敏迪是不是也注意到了？是的。百分之百。百分之百。是的。然后我们收到了苏格兰格拉斯哥的贝卡·H的粉丝提问，她说：“‘别刮我的嘴唇’这句台词是史蒂夫即兴发挥的吗？”
The delivery is so good. I laugh every time. Angela. I went to the shooting draft. It's 100% scripted. It's so hard to believe. It's so perfect. I loved this couplet of dialogue when D'Angelo says, you know what?
The delivery is so good. I laugh every time. Angela. I went to the shooting draft. It's 100% scripted. It's so hard to believe. It's so perfect. I loved this couplet of dialogue when D'Angelo says, you know what?|||他的语气拿捏得太棒了。我每次看都笑。安吉拉。我去查了拍摄剧本。这百分之百是写在剧本里的。简直让人难以置信。太完美了。我超喜欢迪安杰罗说的这几句对话：“你知道吗？|||
Enough about your baby. Okay. I'm sorry. And Jim goes, we were, I think she was just trying to and he goes, no, no, no. I know what you're doing. Just quit it. Yeah. Just quit it.
Enough about your baby. Okay. I'm sorry. And Jim goes, we were, I think she was just trying to and he goes, no, no, no. I know what you're doing. Just quit it. Yeah. Just quit it.|||少聊点你们的宝宝吧。行。对不起。”然后吉姆说：“我们刚才，我觉得她只是想……”迪安杰罗打断道：“不，不，不。我知道你们在搞什么鬼。别装了。对。别再演了。”
He does not want to hear their Dada story about Cece loving a dog. Oh my gosh. But he says, just quit it. I laughed so hard. So right after this scene, Jim and Pam regroup. It's in the extended cut. I wanted you to hear it. Did we just totally blow it?
He does not want to hear their Dada story about Cece loving a dog. Oh my gosh. But he says, just quit it. I laughed so hard. So right after this scene, Jim and Pam regroup. It's in the extended cut. I wanted you to hear it. Did we just totally blow it?|||他才不想听他们讲什么茜茜喜欢狗狗的爸爸妈妈故事呢。哦天哪。但他却说：“别再演了。”我笑得肚子疼。所以在紧接着这场戏之后，吉姆和帕姆重新聚在一起商量。这在加长版里有。我想让你们听听。我们是不是彻底搞砸了？
I don't know. I mean, I get that talking about your kid can be annoying. You know, everybody thinks their kid is the cutest in the world. Cece really is. Right? Yeah. We just got to get her in here. That's their solution.
I don't know. I mean, I get that talking about your kid can be annoying. You know, everybody thinks their kid is the cutest in the world. Cece really is. Right? Yeah. We just got to get her in here. That's their solution.|||我不知道。我是说，我理解谈论自己的孩子可能会让人觉得烦。你知道的，每个人都觉得自己孩子是世界上最可爱的。茜茜确实是。对吧？是的。我们只能把她带到这儿来了。这就是他们的解决方案。
We just got to bring her in. He needs to see her in person. Yep. Mm-hmm. So also during this scene, DeAngelo is going to ask people, how can he be the best manager for them? Like, how could he make things even better? And Michael says, listen, be honest.
We just got to bring her in. He needs to see her in person. Yep. Mm-hmm. So also during this scene, DeAngelo is going to ask people, how can he be the best manager for them? Like, how could he make things even better? And Michael says, listen, be honest.|||我们必须把她带来。他必须亲自见见她。没错。嗯哼。所以在同一场戏中，迪安杰罗询问大家，他要怎样才能成为最棒的经理？比如，他要如何才能让情况变得更好？迈克尔说：“听着，说实话。
It's fine. So Oscar suggests maybe we could have some improved communication, you know, currently every single memo is marked urgent and it's very confusing. And then Michael says he marks them urgent because if he didn't, then no one would read them, but that he has a special system, Urgent A, Urgent B, Urgent C, Urgent D. Everyone knows Urgent D. You can just ignore Urgent A is really urgent. Lady, this reminded me, have I ever told you about the guy I worked for who had the color coded system for his mail and other memos?
It's fine. So Oscar suggests maybe we could have some improved communication, you know, currently every single memo is marked urgent and it's very confusing. And then Michael says he marks them urgent because if he didn't, then no one would read them, but that he has a special system, Urgent A, Urgent B, Urgent C, Urgent D. Everyone knows Urgent D. You can just ignore Urgent A is really urgent. Lady, this reminded me, have I ever told you about the guy I worked for who had the color coded system for his mail and other memos?|||没关系。”于是奥斯卡建议，也许我们可以改善一下沟通，你知道的，目前每一份备忘录都被标记为“紧急”，这让人很混淆。然后迈克尔说，他标记为紧急是因为如果他不这么做，就没人会看了，不过他有一套特殊的系统——紧急A、紧急B、紧急C、紧急D。人人都知道紧急D可以直接忽略，紧急A才是真的紧急。天哪，这让我想起了一件事，我有没有跟你说过我以前有个老板，他的邮件和其他备忘录有一套颜色编码系统？
We've been doing the podcast so long, I can't even remember if I've told the story before. Wait, is this the guy that made you FedEx from the airport? Is this the same guy? Yes, same guy. Oh my God. I don't think I know the folder story. Tell it. Okay.
We've been doing the podcast so long, I can't even remember if I've told the story before. Wait, is this the guy that made you FedEx from the airport? Is this the same guy? Yes, same guy. Oh my God. I don't think I know the folder story. Tell it. Okay.|||我们做播客太久了，我甚至记不清我以前有没有讲过这个故事。等等，这就是那个让你去机场寄联邦快递的家伙吗？是同一个人吗？是的，就是同一个家伙。噢我的天。我觉得我还不知道文件夹的故事呢。讲讲吧。好吧。
I apologize to everyone out there if I've already told this story. So I worked for this guy. I was his administrative assistant. I had to go through his email, his physical mail. I received all memos, interoffice memos, and he had this color coded filing system. There was something like eight different colors and red was urgent. And then like the blue folder meant like executive correspondence. And then the purple folder was to be signed.
I apologize to everyone out there if I've already told this story. So I worked for this guy. I was his administrative assistant. I had to go through his email, his physical mail. I received all memos, interoffice memos, and he had this color coded filing system. There was something like eight different colors and red was urgent. And then like the blue folder meant like executive correspondence. And then the purple folder was to be signed.|||如果我以前讲过这个故事，我要向所有听众道歉。当时我为这个人打工。我是他的行政助理。我得查阅他的电子邮件和实体信件。我接收所有的备忘录、公司内部备忘录，而他有一套颜色编码的文件归档系统。大概有八种不同的颜色，红色代表紧急。然后蓝色的文件夹代表高管信件。紫色文件夹代表需要签字的文件。
Each folder had a different designation, but there was a problem because sometimes there would be something that was like urgent, that was executive correspondence and needed to be signed. And I asked him when I started, what do I do with a piece of mail like this? Which folder do I put it in? And he said, put it in all three. So you had to make three copies and put it in all three? Yes.
Each folder had a different designation, but there was a problem because sometimes there would be something that was like urgent, that was executive correspondence and needed to be signed. And I asked him when I started, what do I do with a piece of mail like this? Which folder do I put it in? And he said, put it in all three. So you had to make three copies and put it in all three? Yes.|||每个文件夹都有不同的指定用途，但问题来了，因为有时候有些邮件既是紧急的，又是高管信件，而且还亟需签字。我刚上班时问过他，遇到这种邮件我该怎么办？我该把它放进哪个文件夹？他说：“全放进去。”所以你得复印三份，然后把三份分别放进三个文件夹？对。
Oh. It was insanity. It was so weird. And it completely reminded me of urgent A, B, D, C. I feel like that man would have created a similar system. Yeah. You know, Jenna, you and I tempt at a lot of places. We had a lot of different bosses while we were struggling actresses.
Oh. It was insanity. It was so weird. And it completely reminded me of urgent A, B, D, C. I feel like that man would have created a similar system. Yeah. You know, Jenna, you and I tempt at a lot of places. We had a lot of different bosses while we were struggling actresses.|||哦。这简直丧心病狂。太诡异了。这完全让我想起了紧急A、B、D、C。我觉得那家伙也会设计出一套类似的系统。是啊。你知道的，珍娜，你我都曾在很多地方做过临时工。在我们作为苦苦挣扎的女演员的时期，我们遇到过形形色色的老板。
And this episode, when I watched it, brought back so many memories of just those random bosses you could have. I had one who would really try to support his workers, which was great. And a few of us were doing a sketch comedy show together and he came to our sketch comedy show. This was one of my bosses at 1-800-Dennis. And you know, in a sketch comedy, you play a lot of wacky characters, right? Yeah.
And this episode, when I watched it, brought back so many memories of just those random bosses you could have. I had one who would really try to support his workers, which was great. And a few of us were doing a sketch comedy show together and he came to our sketch comedy show. This was one of my bosses at 1-800-Dennis. And you know, in a sketch comedy, you play a lot of wacky characters, right? Yeah.|||而这一集，当我看着它的时候，勾起了我关于那些稀奇古怪的老板的许多回忆。我曾有个老板，他真的会极力支持手下的员工，这很棒。当时我们几个人一起在做一个小品喜剧演出，他还专门来看了。这是我在1-800-Dennis工作时的老板之一。你知道的，在小品喜剧里，你要扮演很多古怪滑稽的角色，对吧？对。
And I played all kinds of crazy wacky characters. And I don't think he knew much about me because I just kind of kept to myself, I would come, sit at my station, answer calls from people looking for Dennis, and then I'd leave. But after he came to the sketch show, it's like he thought I was the crazy gal, the crazy wacky gal. I was Andy. You were Andy. Yes.
And I played all kinds of crazy wacky characters. And I don't think he knew much about me because I just kind of kept to myself, I would come, sit at my station, answer calls from people looking for Dennis, and then I'd leave. But after he came to the sketch show, it's like he thought I was the crazy gal, the crazy wacky gal. I was Andy. You were Andy. Yes.|||我扮演过各种各样疯狂滑稽的角色。我觉得他对我不太了解，因为我平时挺独来独往的，我来上班，坐在自己的工位上，接听找丹尼斯的人的电话，然后就下班。但自从他看了那场小品演出后，他就觉得我是个疯狂的女孩，一个疯狂滑稽的女孩。我成了安迪。你成了安迪。是的。
And he would walk past me and he'd be like, she's crazy, she's gonna say something crazy and funny. Oh, no. Yeah. And I'd be like, uh, just like the same thing. So much so he would also say, I bet you know where the parties are. I was like, I don't know where any parties are. I was so boring, you know?
And he would walk past me and he'd be like, she's crazy, she's gonna say something crazy and funny. Oh, no. Yeah. And I'd be like, uh, just like the same thing. So much so he would also say, I bet you know where the parties are. I was like, I don't know where any parties are. I was so boring, you know?|||他从我身边走过时会说：“她可疯了，她一会儿要说出什么疯狂搞笑的话来。”哦，不。是啊。而我就会说：“呃，跟平常一样啦。”以至于他还会说：“我敢打赌你肯定知道哪儿有派对。”我当时心想：我根本不知道哪儿有派对啊。我这人无聊得很，你知道吗？
But all of a sudden he thought I was a crazy wacky gal. Well it sounds like you kind of had a good relationship with him at least. Did you? Sort of? Or did it become a burden? Like it is for Andy? No, it was a total burden. I would like hide from him in the hallway because he would expect me to say something wacky
But all of a sudden he thought I was a crazy wacky gal. Well it sounds like you kind of had a good relationship with him at least. Did you? Sort of? Or did it become a burden? Like it is for Andy? No, it was a total burden. I would like hide from him in the hallway because he would expect me to say something wacky|||但他突然就觉得我是个疯狂滑稽的女孩。好吧，听起来你至少和他关系还不错。是吗？算吗？还是说这成了一种负担？就像安迪那样？不，这完全是个负担。我会在走廊里躲着他，因为他总是期望我说点滑稽|||
or crazy. And I'm like, listen, just because I played a zany newscaster or, you know, the nervous laugh neighbor doesn't mean I'm going to be that when I just want to go to the bathroom. Yeah. I get it. I just don't expect me to be a character when I'm at the vending machine or just trying to go pee. You know, folder guy who sent me to the airport FedEx that one evening, I really didn't care
or crazy. And I'm like, listen, just because I played a zany newscaster or, you6 know, the nervous laugh neighbor doesn't mean I'm going to be that when I just want to go to the bathroom. Yeah. I get it. Just don't expect me to be a character when I'm at the vending machine or just trying to go pee. You know, folder guy who sent me to the airport FedEx that one evening, I really didn't care|||或者疯狂的话。而我会想：听着，仅仅因为我演过一个滑稽的新闻主播或者，你知道的，那个笑起来神经质的邻居，并不意味着当我想去上个厕所时我也得保持那种状态。对。我懂。总之别期望我在自动售货机旁或者只是想去尿尿的时候还在扮演某个角色。你知道的，那个让我去机场寄联邦快递的文件夹男，我真的挺讨厌|||
for him and I did snark him out one day and it was really liberating. As you can probably surmise, he was a very controlling personality type and I was working at an office that was very contained. You couldn't leave for lunch. There was nothing around. It was a very industrial area. So you had to eat in their cafeteria and there was a little outdoor courtyard and his office looked out over the outdoor courtyard.
for him and I did snark him out one day and it was really liberating. As you can probably surmise, he was a very controlling personality type and I was working at an office that was very contained. You couldn't leave for lunch. There was nothing around. It was a very industrial area. So you had to eat in their cafeteria and there was a little outdoor courtyard and his office looked out over the outdoor courtyard.|||他的，我有一天终于忍不住狠狠顶撞了他一次，那感觉简直太解气了。正如你大概能猜到的那样，他是个极具控制欲的人，而我当时在一个管理非常封闭的办公室上班。午休时间你不能离开公司。周围什么也没有。那是个工业区。所以你必须在他们的食堂吃饭，那里有一个小室外庭院，而他的办公室刚好能俯瞰那个室外庭院。
He had a window. He could see everybody out his window. So one day after lunch, I only got a half hour lunch. By the way, unpaid. I'd like to say that I did not get to put that half hour on my time card. He called me into his office and he said, um, I was watching you during lunch. Oh, he said, I noticed that you put your head down on the table. I don't know.
He had a window. He could see everybody out his window. So one day after lunch, I only got a half hour lunch. By the way, unpaid. I'd like to say that I did not get to put that half hour on my time card. He called me into his office and he said, um, I was watching you during lunch. Oh, he said, I noticed that you put your head down on the table. I don't know.|||他有扇窗户。他通过窗户能看到外面的所有人。所以有一天午饭后，我只有半小时的午休时间。顺便说一句，这是没工资的。我想说的是，这半小时我根本不能记进考勤卡里。他把我叫进办公室，说道：“嗯，我午饭时一直在观察你。”哦，他说：“我注意到你把头埋在桌子上。我不知道。
Maybe you were taking a little nap and I said, I did. I was tired after I ate. I laid my head down and I closed my eyes. It's a nice day out. I felt the sunshine. It felt really good. He said, yeah, you know what, that's really unprofessional. This isn't a place to take a nap.
Maybe you were taking a little nap and I said, I did. I was tired after I ate. I laid my head down and I closed my eyes. It's a nice day out. I felt the sunshine. It felt really good. He said, yeah, you know what, that's really unprofessional. This isn't a place to take a nap.|||也许你在打个小盹。”我说：“没错。我吃完饭觉得累了。我把头趴下，闭上了眼睛。外面天气很好。我感受到了阳光。感觉真的很舒服。”他说：“是啊，你知道吗，这太不专业了。这里可不是睡觉的地方。
This is a workplace. Oh my God. What'd you say? I said, well, since you're not paying me for my half hour lunch, I'm going to do whatever I want. I said, if you'd like to pay me for that time, then you can give me instructions on how to behave, but otherwise I'll do whatever I'd like during my half hour of unpaid time here in this building that I can't leave.
This is a workplace. Oh my God. What's you say? I said, well, since you're not paying me for my half hour lunch, I'm going to do whatever I want. I said, if you'd like to pay me for that time, then you can give me instructions on how to behave, but otherwise I'll do whatever I'd like during my half hour of unpaid time here in this building that I can't leave.|||这里是工作场所。”我的天哪。你当时说什么了？我说：“好吧，既然你这半小时午休不给我付工资，那我想干嘛就干嘛。我说，如果你愿意为那段时间付工钱，那你就可以指导我该怎么表现，否则在这栋我无法离开的大楼里，在我这半小时的无薪时间里，我想干什么就干什么。”
And then I walked out. I love it. Cause I had kind of had enough. I was like, I'll make your multiple copies for your dumb colored folders and I'll drive your last minute work that you couldn't get around to down to the airport. But because of all that, I'm going to need to lay my head down at lunchtime because you're a major headache in my life and I need a second. I love that.
And then I walked out. I love it. Cause I had kind of had enough. I was like, I'll make your multiple copies for your dumb colored folders and I'll drive your last minute work that you couldn't get around to down to the airport. But because of all that, I'm going to need to lay my head down at lunchtime because you're a major headache in my life and I need a second. I love that.|||然后我就扬长而去了。太棒了。因为我当时真的是受够了。我想：我会帮你那蠢货彩色文件夹复印多份，我也会开车把那些你赶不及做的最后一分钟工作送到机场去。但正因为这一切，我午休时必须得把头趴下休息一会儿，因为你是我生命中的巨大折磨，我需要清静一会儿。我太喜欢了。
I love it. Here's the thing I knew in that moment. I knew that he couldn't fire me because I knew he didn't want to train someone new to do all of his weird folder and so I had the tiniest bit of agency and I cashed it in in that moment. And I'm glad I did because the look on his face was priceless and I still think back to it today. He was speechless.
I love it. Here's the thing I knew in that moment. I knew that he couldn't fire me because I knew he didn't want to train someone new to do all of his weird folder and so I had the tiniest bit of agency and I cashed it in in that moment. And I'm glad I did because the look on his face was priceless and I still think back to it today. He was speechless.|||我太爱了。当时我心里清楚一件事。我知道他不敢开除我，因为我知道他不想重新培训新人来搞他那些奇奇怪怪的文件夹，所以我当时拥有那么一点点主动权，并在那一刻把它给兑现了。我很高兴我这么做了，因为他当时脸上的表情简直无价，直到今天我回想起来都觉得好笑。他当时气得说不出话来。
He did not know how to respond to that. Oh my gosh. I don't know how this turned into stories about our early days working, but apparently we needed to get this out as therapeutic Jenna, we're talking about all of our old bosses. I feel better. I do too. Next, we're going to move into the break room. DeAngelo is having lunch.
He did not know how to respond to that. Oh my gosh. I don't know how this turned into stories about our early days working, but apparently we needed to get this out as therapeutic Jenna, we're talking about all of our old bosses. I feel better. I do too. Next, we're going to move into the break room. DeAngelo is having lunch.|||他根本不知道该怎么回话。哦天哪。我不知道怎么聊着聊着就聊到我们早期打工的故事了，但显然我们需要把这些倒出来当成心理治疗，珍娜，我们把以前的老板都数落了一遍。我感觉好多了。我也是。接下来，我们要转到休息室。迪安杰罗正在吃午饭。
Did you look at his plate? Can we talk about it for a second? What was on his plate? Here I took a picture of it. He has a Tupperware container that looks like it has broccoli, but then there's another Tupperware container that's open that looks like it has bean sprouts. But what is on his plate? Is that a stalk of lettuce?
Did you look at his plate? Can we talk about it for a second? What was on his plate? Here I took a picture of it. He has a Tupperware container that looks like it has broccoli, but then there's another Tupperware container that's open that looks like it has bean sprouts. But what is on his plate? Is that a stalk of lettuce?|||你看了他的盘子吗？我们能聊一聊吗？他盘子里装的是什么？我拍了张照片。他有一个特百惠保鲜盒，里面好像是西兰花，然后旁边另一个打开的保鲜盒里好像装着豆芽。但他的盘子里到底是什么？那是根生菜吗？
It looks like maybe he's chopped off the bottom of the celery and he just has the top. What is he eating? I don't know. He's eating a lot of nothing. I went to the script. It doesn't have any direction for this. I was so very confused. Jenna, I know why he's eating all of that, but I'm not going to tell you yet.
It looks like maybe he's chopped off the bottom of the celery and he just has the top. What is he eating? I don't know. He's eating a lot of nothing. I went to the script. It doesn't have any direction for this. I was so very confused. Jenna, I know why he's eating all of that, but I'm not going to tell you yet.|||看起来好像是他把西芹根部切掉了，只留了顶部。他到底在吃什么？我不知道。他吃的全是空气。我翻了剧本。剧本里对这个完全没有任何说明。我当时困惑极了。珍娜，我知道他为什么在吃那些东西，但我现在不告诉你。
What? I'm not going to tell you. It's in the extended cut. It comes later in the episode, The Explanation. I'm going to save it. Well, I was very confused when the scene opened, so I'm excited that I'm going to get some answers. Okay.
What? I'm not going to tell you. It's in the extended cut. It comes later in the episode, The Explanation. I'm going to save it. Well, I was very confused when the scene opened, so I'm excited that I'm going to get some answers. Okay.|||什么？我才不告诉你呢。加长版里有。在这一集后面的剧情里会有解释。我先卖个关子。好吧，这场戏刚开始时我满头雾水，所以我很高兴接下来能得到答案。好吧。
Well, Andy thinks he's written the perfect joke. He's going to tell DeAngelo since he's the office funny guy. DeAngelo doesn't even think he's telling a joke. He thinks he's getting political and he's like, you know what, just stick to being the funny guy. All right? You're the funny guy. No politics.
Well, Andy thinks he's written the perfect joke. He's going to tell DeAngelo since he's the office funny guy. DeAngelo doesn't even think he's telling a joke. He thinks he's getting political and he's like, you know what, just stick to being the funny guy. All right? You're the funny guy. No politics.|||好吧，安迪觉得自己写出了一个完美的笑话。既然迪安杰罗是办公室的搞笑达人，他打算把这个笑话讲给迪安杰罗听。迪安杰罗甚至不觉得他在讲笑话。他觉得安迪这是在谈论政治，然后他说：“你知道吗，老老实实当你的搞笑达人就行了。好吗？你是个搞笑达人。别谈政治。
Just be the funny guy. Poor Andy. Andy's like, okay, and he starts to back out of the room and he legitimately trips and kind of falls on this table and it all tips over and DeAngelo is like, yes, funny guy. We had a fan catch from Shannon M. in Clinton Township, Michigan, who said at 14 minutes and 50 seconds when Andy trips and falls and pulls the table down. As the table is going down, I noticed a blue square under the table and thought it might be a sticky note telling production what set this table belongs to and what position it
Just be the funny guy. Poor Andy. Andy's like, okay, and he starts to back out of the room and he legitimately trips and kind of falls on this table and it all tips over and DeAngelo is like, yes, funny guy. We had a fan catch from Shannon M. in Clinton Township, Michigan, who said at 14 minutes and 50 seconds when Andy trips and falls and pulls the table down. As the table is going down, I noticed a blue square under the table and thought it might be a sticky note telling production what set this table belongs to and what position it|||只管搞笑就行。”可怜的安迪。安迪说：“好吧，”然后他开始往房间外退，结果真的绊了一下，整个人扑到了桌子上，桌子瞬间翻了个底朝天，迪安杰罗见状便说：“没错，不愧是搞笑达人。”我们收到了来自密歇根州克林顿镇的香农·M的粉丝捕捉，她说在14分50秒时，当安迪绊倒并把桌子拉翻时。在桌子倒下去的过程中，她注意到桌子底下有一个蓝色的方块，觉得那可能是一张便签，用来告诉制作组这张桌子属于哪个布景，以及它应该摆在什么|||
goes in which room. Am I right? Yes, Shannon. You are right. Remember when we saw that sticky tape under Pam's desk that said Pam's desk? Yeah. We had little pieces of tape on all of the furniture saying what it was and where it went.
goes in which room. Am I right? Yes, Shannon. You are right. Remember when we saw that sticky tape under Pam's desk that said Pam's desk? Yeah. We had little pieces of tape on all of the furniture saying what it was and where it went.|||位置。我说的对吗？是的，香农。你说的对。还记得我们当时看到帕姆办公桌底下贴着写有“帕姆的桌子”的胶带吗？对。我们所有的家具上都贴了小纸条，写着它是什么以及该放在哪里。
One of the things that just delights me is that everyone is becoming so good at background catches and I can't wait to see what people catch each week. DeAngelo is going to get a huge box. Erin's like, your stuff is here. Everyone gathers around. It's a lot of Southwest decor. It reminded me of the stuff in our trailers. Yes.
One of the things that just delights me is that everyone is becoming so good at background catches and I can't wait to see what people catch each week. DeAngelo is going to get a huge box. Erin's like, your stuff is here. Everyone gathers around. It's a lot of Southwest decor. It reminded me of the stuff in our trailers. Yes.|||最令我开心的一点是，大家现在越来越擅长捕捉背景细节了，我迫不及待地想看看大家每周都能发现什么彩蛋。迪安杰罗收到一个巨大的箱子。艾琳说：“你的东西到了。”大家都围了过来。里面全都是西南风格的装饰品。这让我想起了我们化妆休息车里的东西。对。
Remember our trailers had a Southwest decor. Yeah. Michael has a talking head where he says, you know, DeAngelo is a great guy. He loves the guy. He's not sure if he's the right fit for the office. Also I'm not sure if I love the guy. Yeah. People are going to keep trying to suck up to DeAngelo.
Remember our trailers had a Southwest decor. Yeah. Michael has a talking head where he says, you know, DeAngelo is a great guy. He loves the guy. He's not sure if he's the right fit for the office. Also I'm not sure if I love the guy. Yeah. People are going to keep trying to suck up to DeAngelo.|||还记得我们的化妆车就有西南风格的装饰吗。对。迈克尔有一段单人访谈，他说：“你知道的，迪安杰罗是个好人。他很喜欢这家伙。他不确定这家伙是否适合办公室。另外，我也不确定我是不是喜欢这家伙。”是的。大家会继续试着拍迪安杰罗的马屁。
Darrell's sister is going to swing by the office and drop off some cowboy boots and a cowboy hat that Darrell is now going to wear. Yeah. He had a talking head. It's in the extended cut that explains his new love of the Southwest. Let's hear it. No, I've always loved the Southwest. I got a lot of this stuff at home, you know, turquoise and rocks.
Darrell's sister is going to swing by the office and drop off some cowboy boots and a cowboy hat that Darrell is now going to wear. Yeah. He had a talking head. It's in the extended cut that explains his new love of the Southwest. Let's hear it. No, I've always loved the Southwest. I got a lot of this stuff at home, you know, turquoise and rocks.|||达里尔的妹妹顺路来到办公室，送来了一双牛仔靴和一顶牛仔帽，达里尔现在要把它穿戴上了。对。他有一段单人访谈。在加长版里，这段访谈解释了他对西南风情的新热爱。我们来听听。不，我一直都很喜欢西南风情。我家里有很多这种东西，你知道的，绿松石和石头。
I need this job, man. He just looks very... I mean, he gets right to the point. Yeah. He starts like going off and then he's like, who am I kidding? Look, I just need this job, okay? Poor Andy is now going to walk past DeAngelo on his way to the bathroom. And once again, he's got to be office funny guy.
I need this job, man. He just looks very... I mean, he gets right to the point. Yeah. He starts like going off and then he's like, who am I kidding? Look, I just need this job, okay? Poor Andy is now going to walk past DeAngelo on his way to the bathroom. And once again, he's got to be office funny guy.|||我需要这份工作，兄弟。他看起来非常……我的意思是，他直接开门见山了。对。他先是滔滔不绝地说了一堆，然后突然话锋一转：“我在自欺欺人个什么劲？听着，我就是需要这份工作，行了吧？”可怜的安迪现在要去上厕所，路过了迪安杰罗身边。他得再次扮演办公室的搞笑达人。
I so related to him in this moment, this would be like me just wanting to go to the bathroom. But now my boss is like, hey, sketch comedy girl, be funny, do a sketch, do an accent. And I'm like, I'm just getting the key to go pee. Thanks. So in this scene, Andy is first going to kind of do like some funny miming. Yeah. Like he's pulling a rope. Yeah.
I so related to him in this moment, this would be like me just wanting to go to the bathroom. But now my boss is like, hey, sketch comedy girl, be funny, do a sketch, do an accent. And I'm like, I'm just getting the key to go pee. Thanks. So in this scene, Andy is first going to kind of do like some funny miming. Yeah. Like he's pulling a rope. Yeah.|||这一刻我太感同身受了，这就好比我只是想去个洗手间。但现在我的老板却说：“嘿，小品喜剧女孩，搞笑点，来个小品，来个口音。”而我心里想的是：我只是在拿去尿尿的钥匙谢谢。所以在这一场戏里，安迪首先会做一些滑稽的哑剧动作。对。就像他在拉一根绳子一样。对。
But DeAngelo is not liking it until it escalates. He's going to pour hot coffee on his crotch, which really makes DeAngelo laugh. And then DeAngelo says, drink this hand soap and Andy starts pumping the hand soap into his mouth. Yeah. This is after he's stuck his hand in a toaster, tossed tea bags and cheese puffs all over himself. I had to look in the script about this.
But DeAngelo is not liking it until it escalates. He's going to pour hot coffee on his crotch, which really makes DeAngelo laugh. And then DeAngelo says, drink this hand soap and Andy starts pumping the hand soap into his mouth. Yeah. This is after he's stuck his hand in a toaster, tossed tea bags and cheese puffs all over himself. I had to look in the script about this.|||但迪安杰罗并不买账，直到情况升级。他把热咖啡倒在自己的裤裆上，这真的把迪安杰罗逗笑了。然后迪安杰罗说：“把这洗手液喝了，”于是安迪开始把洗手液挤进嘴里。对。这发生在他把手伸进烤面包机、把茶包和奶酪膨化食品撒满全身之后。我为此不得不去查了剧本。
I wanted to know what was written and what was improvised. Yes. Because I felt like I could see a glimmer in Will's eyes when he said, drink this hand soap. And I felt like I saw Ed kind of laugh at the idea as Ed, but then do it. It is not scripted. Oh no. I texted Ed and Ed said it was an improv by Will and he gave it a big ol' yes hand.
I wanted to know what was written and what was improvised. Yes. Because I felt like I could see a glimmer in Will's eyes when he said, drink this hand soap. And I felt like I saw Ed kind of laugh at the idea as Ed, but then do it. It is not scripted. Oh no. I texted Ed and Ed said it was an improv by Will and he gave it a big ol' yes hand.|||我想知道哪些是写好的，哪些是即兴发挥的。是的。因为我觉得当威尔说“把这洗手液喝了”时，我能看到他眼里的闪光。而且我觉得我看到埃德作为埃德本人对这个主意笑了笑，然后照做了。这根本不是剧本里写的。哦，不。我给埃德发了短信，埃德说那是威尔的即兴发挥，而且他当时大力赞同了。
What did he squirt in his mouth? Did he actually? Oh my gosh. It was just sitting there. He just did it. And I feel like Will was joking when he said, do the hand soap because the scene was over. The scene was supposed to end with the hot coffee. And I think Will was kidding because you can even see, I feel like I, knowing Will, he's
What did he squirt in his mouth? Did he actually? Oh my gosh. It was just sitting there. He just did it. And I feel like Will was joking when he said, do the hand soap because the scene was over. The scene was supposed to end with the hot coffee. And I think Will was kidding because you can even see, I feel like I, knowing Will, he's|||他往嘴里挤了什么？他真的挤了吗？哦天哪。那瓶子就放在那儿。他直接就这么干了。我觉得威尔说“弄点洗手液”时只是在开玩笑，因为那场戏本来已经结束了。这场戏原本应该在倒热咖啡那里结束。我觉得威尔当时是在开玩笑，因为你甚至能看到——我觉得我了解威尔，他就是那种|||
like, do the hand soap like as a bit, as a joke. But Ed was like, okay, I'm up for it. And you can kind of see in the scene, Ed's pumping it, but it's really just hitting his lips. It's not going all the way in his mouth. Oh. Yeah, that was a fun text exchange with Ed. He enjoyed remembering that moment.
like, do the hand soap like as a bit, as a joke. But Ed was like, okay, I'm up for it. And you can kind of see in the scene, Ed's pumping it, but it's really just hitting his lips. It's not going all the way in his mouth. Oh. Yeah, that was a fun text exchange with Ed. He enjoyed remembering that moment.|||会把“用洗手液”当成一个段子、一个玩笑的人。但埃德却觉得：好吧，我奉陪。你能在镜头里看到，埃德在按压洗手液，但其实只是抹到了他的嘴唇上。并没有真的全部挤进嘴里。哦。是的，我和埃德的那次短信交流很有趣。他很乐意回忆起那个时刻。
It's going to cut to an Andy talking head where he's like, I guess this is my life now. So after this Andy talking head, Jenna, we would have found out a little backstory about DeAngelo that might have explained his lunch choice. Oh, I'm getting my answer. Yep. All right. There is a huge scene. It's in the extended cut.
It's going to cut to an Andy talking head where he's like, I guess this is my life now. So after this Andy talking head, Jenna, we would have found out a little backstory about DeAngelo that might have explained his lunch choice. Oh, I'm getting my answer. Yep. All right. There is a huge scene. It's in the extended cut.|||画面将切到安迪的单人访谈，他在访谈里说：“我想这就是我现在的生活了。”所以在这段安迪的单人访谈之后，珍娜，我们本可以了解到关于迪安杰罗的一点背景故事，这或许能解释他午餐的选择。哦，我要得到答案了。没错。好的。有一场非常重头的戏。在加长版里有。
I'm not going to play it because it's so big. That's what she said. Yes. Basically, Dwight wants to try to sabotage DeAngelo and he finds an old photo of him where DeAngelo is very, very overweight. He takes this picture and he shows it to Michael. And Michael also now wants to sabotage DeAngelo, right? Because everyone likes him.
I'm not going to play it because it's so big. That's what she said. Yes. Basically, Dwight wants to try to sabotage DeAngelo and he finds an old photo of him where DeAngelo is very, very overweight. He takes this picture and he shows it to Michael. And Michael also now wants to sabotage DeAngelo, right? Because everyone likes him.|||我不打算放出来，因为这太重磅了。这话听着耳熟。是的。基本上，德怀特想要试图破坏迪安杰罗的计划，他找到了一张迪安杰罗过去非常非常胖的老照片。他拿着这张照片给迈克尔看。而迈克尔现在也想破坏迪安杰罗的好事，对吧？因为大家都喜欢迪安杰罗。
So he brings it out into the bullpen and shows it to everyone. Like sort of thinking that they're going to shame DeAngelo or embarrass him in some way. That's right. But DeAngelo walks in the room and he sees the picture being passed around and he's like, you know what? Yeah. That was my life, you know, and it's taken me a long journey to get where I am.
So he brings it out into the bullpen and shows it to everyone. Like sort of thinking that they're going to shame DeAngelo or embarrass him in some way. That's right. But DeAngelo walks in the room and he sees the picture being passed around and he's like, you know what? Yeah. That was my life, you know, and it's taken me a long journey to get where I am.|||于是他把照片拿到大办公区展示给所有人看。心里大概盘算着这样能让迪安杰罗感到羞耻，或者以某种方式让他难堪。没错。但迪安杰罗走进房间，看到照片在大家手里传阅，便说道：“你知道吗？是的。那就是我曾经的生活，你们懂的，我经历了一漫长的旅程才走到今天。”
And he ends up giving this very inspirational speech and tells everyone in the bullpen that he believes in them that they're going to be the best they can be at Dunder Mifflin because he could believe in himself. When it ends in this rousing applause, the whole team is now more behind him than ever. And Michael is so annoyed. It completely backfired on Michael and Dwight. Well, Michael's going to have to find a new way to sabotage DeAngelo. So he walks in on DeAngelo talking to all of us about whale watching and Michael has
And he ends up giving this very inspirational speech and tells everyone in the bullpen that he believes in them that they're going to be the best they can be at Dunder Mifflin because he could believe in himself. When it ends in this rousing applause, the whole team is now more behind him than ever. And Michael is so annoyed. It completely backfired on Michael and Dwight. Well, Michael's going to have to find a new way to sabotage DeAngelo. So he walks in on DeAngelo talking to all of us about whale watching and Michael has|||最后他发表了一番非常鼓舞人心的演讲，告诉大办公区的每一个人，他相信他们，相信他们能在邓德·米夫林做到最好，因为他自己能够相信自己。在一阵雷鸣般的掌声中结束时，整个团队现在比以往任何时候都更加支持他了。而迈克尔气坏了。这完全起到了反效果，坑了迈克尔和德怀特。好吧，迈克尔不得不寻找新的方法来破坏迪安杰罗。于是他撞见迪安杰罗正在跟我们大家讲关于赏鲸的事，迈克尔便
brought in peanut butter and jelly sandwiches, even though DeAngelo has a serious peanut allergy. His allergy is so serious, we find out it makes him itchy for a few days. Mm-hmm. Yes. I got curious about whale watching because DeAngelo is saying the best whale watching is on the West Coast. Yeah.
带了花生酱和果冻三明治，尽管迪安杰罗对花生严重过敏。他的过敏太严重了，我们发现这会让他的皮肤发痒好几天。嗯哼。是的。我对赏鲸产生了兴趣，因为迪安杰罗说西海岸是赏鲸最好的地方。是的。
Not the East Coast. Well, he loves the West. He sure does. According to an article in Local Adventurer called the 15 Best Places to Whale Watch in the U.S., the best whale watching is in Glacier Bay, Alaska, in June through August. You can see humpbacks, orcas, and blue whales. I know Alaska from April to November is another great spot, and Kodiak Island in Alaska is a great place to see gray whales.
不是东海岸。嗯，他喜欢西部。他确实喜欢。根据《本地冒险家》上的一篇名为《全美15个最佳赏鲸地》的文章，最好的赏鲸地点是阿拉斯加的冰川湾，时间是六月到八月。你可以看到座头鲸、虎鲸和蓝鲸。我知道阿拉斯加从四月到十一月是另一个好地方，阿拉斯加的科迪亚克岛是观看灰鲸的好地方。
In fact, Angela, every April, Kodiak, Alaska has a 10-day festival celebrating the return of the Eastern Pacific gray whale to the area. What do you think? Sign me up. I think we need to go to this festival. I think that's a yes. Anyone out there ever been to the festival, what tips can you give us? What can you tell us about it?
事实上，安吉拉，每年四月，阿拉斯加的科迪亚克都会举办一个为期10天的节日，庆祝东太平洋灰鲸重返该地区。你觉得怎么样？算我一个。我觉得我们需要去参加这个节日。我想这是一个肯定的回答。外面的任何人去过这个节日吗，你能给我们什么建议？你能给我们讲讲它吗？
Even days. The festival. The big festival. It is. The next top spots are all in California, Big Sur, Monterey Bay, San Diego, and Santa Barbara. Also on the West Coast, you've got Hawaii and San Juan Island, Washington, and Depot Bay in Oregon. But there were a few East Coast spots on the list, DeAngelo, I'm sorry to say.
双日。这个节日。盛大的节日。是的。接下来的顶级景点都在加利福尼亚州，大瑟尔、蒙特雷湾、圣迭戈和圣巴巴拉。同样在西海岸，你还有夏威夷和华盛顿州的圣胡安岛，以及俄勒冈州的代波特湾。但是名单上也有几个东海岸的景点，迪安杰罗，我很遗憾地这么说。
You're wrong about the East Coast. If you go to Jacksonville, Florida, Cape Cod, Massachusetts, Long Island, New York, or Virginia Beach, Virginia, there is great whale watching. So there you have it. Well, I just like that DeAngelo brought up whale watching to begin with. I just like that he got the conversation going. He has a lot of interest. He does.
你对东海岸的看法是错的。如果你去佛罗里达州杰克逊维尔、马萨诸塞州科德角、纽约州长岛或弗吉尼亚州弗吉尼亚比奇，那里的赏鲸活动非常棒。所以事实就是这样。好吧，我只是喜欢迪安杰罗一开始就提出赏鲸的事。我只是喜欢他挑起了谈话。他有很多兴趣。他确实有。
Did anyone catch the fact that Brian as Kevin caught a peanut butter and jelly sandwich in his mouth? I noticed it and I went to the script because I wanted to know if that was a scripted bit. Here's what the script said. The script says, Kevin tries to catch the sandwich in his mouth. So it was just that he was supposed to try. It was not required that he catch it. And I have a memory of us all being very delighted that he actually caught it.
有人注意到布莱恩饰演的凯文用嘴接住了一个花生酱果冻三明治吗？我注意到了，我去查了剧本，因为我想知道那是不是剧本里写好的桥段。剧本是这样写的。剧本说，凯文试图用嘴接住三明治。所以这只是要求他去尝试。并没有要求他一定要接住。我记忆中我们所有人都为他真的接住了感到非常高兴。
That he caught it. Yeah. Once again, Michael's plan does not work. People are really annoyed with him that he's trying to sabotage DeAngelo. And DeAngelo's going to call a meeting in the multi-purpose room. He sure is. And everyone's going to go, leaving Michael outside. But DeAngelo is going to come out of the conference room before the meeting starts.
他接住了。是的。迈克尔的计划又一次失败了。人们真的很生他的气，因为他试图破坏迪安杰罗。迪安杰罗要在多功能室召开一个会议。他当然会的。每个人都要去，把迈克尔留在外面。但是迪安杰罗会在会议开始前从会议室出来。
And he's going to ask Michael for some advice. He said, how do you typically start these meetings? Michael says he starts with a little chit chat and a couple of jokes. He tells DeAngelo, you might want to develop a couple of characters. They end up hugging it out in a really kind of awkward weird hug. It's like a, I don't even know, it's like a, they're both facing the same way hug. Yes. Michael's like, why'd you have to be so damn good?
他要向迈克尔征求一些建议。他说，你通常是怎么开始这些会议的？迈克尔说他从一些闲聊和几个笑话开始。他告诉迪安杰罗，你可能想塑造几个角色。他们最终以一种非常尴尬诡异的拥抱抱在了一起。这就像是一个，我甚至不知道，这就像是一个，他们都面向同一个方向的拥抱。是的。迈克尔说，你为什么非得这么优秀呢？
They hold one another in this hug. And it seems as though everything's going to be okay. DeAngelo goes into the conference room. Michael goes into his office and the transition of power has begun. Well, the show's going to end with Jim and Pam bringing CeCe in. This is their plan, you know, to finally really win over DeAngelo. DeAngelo says that's a cute baby. They're so happy.
他们这样拥抱彼此。看起来一切都会好起来的。迪安杰罗走进会议室。迈克尔走进他的办公室，权力交接已经开始了。好吧，节目将在吉姆和帕姆带着西西进来时结束。这是他们的计划，你知道的，为了最终真正赢得迪安杰罗的芳心。迪安杰罗说那是个可爱的宝宝。他们太高兴了。
They fist pump. They're in it. They're in. But the episode ends with DeAngelo's talking head saying, that baby could be the star of a show called Babies I Don't Care About. And that, my friends, is training day. I want to let you know, in case you were curious, Miles McNutt gave this episode a C+. What?
他们击拳庆祝。他们融入进去了。他们成功了。但这一集的结尾是迪安杰罗的访谈镜头，他说，那个宝宝可以成为一个名为《我不在乎的宝宝》的节目的明星。我的朋友们，这就是培训日。我想让你知道，如果你好奇的话，迈尔斯·麦克纳特给这一集打了个C+。什么？
I know. Miles, I loved this episode. Me too. It has no Todd Packer. What's your problem with it? I have to tell you, I'm now obsessed with knowing what Miles thinks of every episode. It's become a new thing for me. I want to know.
我知道。迈尔斯，我很喜欢这一集。我也是。这里面没有托德·帕克尔。你对它有什么意见？我得告诉你，我现在痴迷于想知道迈尔斯对每一集的看法。这成了我的新习惯。我想知道。
I want to know. How did he feel about it? I don't know. When are we going to get an A from Miles? That's what I want to know. Maybe never. What's it going to take? Is it going to be Michael's last dundies?
我想知道。他是怎么看待它的？我不知道。我们什么时候能从迈尔斯那里得到一个A？这就是我想知道的。也许永远不会。这需要什么条件？难道要等到迈克尔的最后一次丹迪奖吗？
Is it going to be good by Michael? I'll let you know. We'll see. I can't wait to hear. Well, a big thank you to Randy Cordray, Ellie Kemper, and Ed Helms for giving us some nice little tidbits for this episode. And if you have the DVD, go watch the extended cut. There's a lot of fun stuff in there.
难道要等到迈克尔再见吗？我会让你知道的。我们走着瞧。我迫不及待想听到了。好吧，非常感谢兰迪·科德雷、埃利·肯珀和埃德·赫尔姆斯为这一集提供了一些精彩的小花絮。如果你有DVD，去看看加长版。里面有很多有趣的内容。
We will be back next week with Michael's last dundies. Oh my gosh, I can't believe it. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoke.
我们下周将带着迈克尔的最后一次丹迪奖回归。哦天哪，我简直不敢相信。到时候见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人工是艾恩斯利·巴比科克。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。要收听无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。要免费试用一个月Stitcher Premium，请使用代码 OFFICE。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可留下评论。